what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame yo what's going on people
King rich is back again with another
podcast good evening and hi and welcome
to Auntie Jenny's video channel to
Jenny's podcast it's your boy The Fresh
Prince of someone
coffee free for four months okay I gotta
say that how could everyone have someone
out there for them when there's more
women than men now I'm not saying you
have to be submissive to every old waste
man walking around I'm just saying that
it would be femininity would be in your
nature breaking it is to find somebody
you're compatible with that you like not
just if you're saying generation and
that likes the same things that you do
going out having fun okay okay then then
get out then get out after Esther then
get out I'm not here to get canceled
today most men want a woman that has
some degree of femininity where they
feel like they're taking care of taking
care of I'm lady night I'm submissive
and you'd be surprised because I will
say what I want to say now and I'll say
what I want to say with my mind but my
demeanor doesn't change and I'm gonna
look down on him because at the end of
the day whoever you're with is a
reflection of you what has happened to
society that has made the normal man a
waste man I would feel so so bad asking
a guy to buy like a three thousand
dollar bag
[Music]
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and bring that
notification Bell that we are going to
be notified of my daily videos like the
video on your way and let's get started
a couple announcements before we start
the show the first is that we have four
membership tiers the first tier gets you
to be a part of the live chat tonight
king um how many likes to open up the
chat tonight
a thousand likes guys and we'll open up
the chat tonight to everybody second
tier you get to be a part of our Discord
and our behind the scenes Vlogs third
tier you get to connect with me on
social media and the fourth tier you get
a one-on-one call with me once a month
do you want to know how to get a million
subscribers in a year I'll tell you make
sure you sign up also guys um super
chats if you want to submit a question
for the panel send a Super Chat king um
how many Super Chat like what what
number for us to read them today over
what
over twenty dollars we will read your
super chat
um also guys
um make sure you subscribe to wife
school we have a new episode coming out
soon also
um Rumble we have the Nick Fuentes video
so if you want to see those go on to
rumble also guys
um we have three talents at the network
um fresh prince of Zamunda I'm King
riches and Auntie Jenny so make sure you
go subscribe to all three uh follow the
pregame page on Instagram and
um sign up to our Google form if you
want to be event notified of our events
um we're gonna do some when we go to the
US next month and we're gonna maybe do
one before we go we might do a meet up
so we'll see but okay so welcome to the
show guys um to start everyone you're
gonna do your name your age your
relationship status and a fun fact about
yourself I'm starting here go around and
then we'll do second row
hi my name is savvy I'm 23 years old and
I'm in the relationship and
I'm here to have fun with you guys
hi my name is Vishay Monroe 23. I'm also
in a relationship and I'm also here to
have a lovely conversation with these
people tonight
hi I'm Taylor I'm 22. I'm single and a
fun fact about me well I drink pickle
juice that's yeah that's my favorite
thing to drink you think it's good it's
not good it's so bad for me but I'm
addicted to drinking it oh wow I know
it's not like a health thing no oh you
just you just genuinely like I love it
wow okay
hi I'm Katie I'm 35. I'm engaged and my
fun fact is we're getting married this
September oh yeah hey
yeah that'll sound like a monster that's
a fun fact okay
um I'm 42 years old and my relationship
status I'm in a relationship and uh fun
fact about me is that I am very blunt
very brutal I like that it's fun
so my name is Ryan
um I'm 21 years old and
my relationship status I am currently
single and uh
yeah
hey guys Dimitri talks her chief
executive officer for lgbg fashion house
you guys see me on social I'm the guy
that designs those fancy suits for
Jordan Peterson that's our company lgfg
like look good feel good lgbg.com uh fun
fact about me is on Thursday I'm driving
up to Newcastle we're going to be
filming me working out with Eddie Hall
so Eddie Hall's gonna take his tailor to
a workout you're gonna see me get
crushed under a lot of weight
uh hey hi I'm Henry I'm 34. and I'm
happily married for just about four
years
and fun fact about me
um this is my first podcast
so it's cool
welcome to the show guys so today we're
talking about high value women is there
such a thing as a high value woman
if so what does that look like start
here go around
I think there is a high value woman
because
[Music]
um
I like I know that men care about
women's past and women care about a
man's future so
I think men do
look for a high value woman
that's what I think so what what so what
traits does does she have
so she's like what a virgin you just
said that they care about their past
like what what is well like I can't
really answer that because I feel like
every man has its own okay you don't
think there's any general things it's
just you don't know
um maybe like body count I feel like
some guys care about body count and
what women do for a living and their
mindsets and their goals in life
what do you think
uh I think there is high value women I
think
they have to have some traits like you
have to be motivated you have to
motivate me in some way that all self to
be family orientated because I'm big on
family so that's definitely high value
and I will say
I don't know because some people has
passed and they have history you know
but you can't really judge them from
that so I don't know if that you can't
judge for on their past yeah it's like
can I judge a man if he has a past of
like prison
uh
you can but that person can't change
though so oh I shouldn't
you want your dog like your daughter
your sister going out with a guy
the prison but me personally if I meet
the guy and I like him oh wow in some
ways I think that's bad advice
who here guys who daughter prison pass
you're cool with anyone listen if the
dude was in prison from a less than a
kid and you're like but I like them you
might want to rethink
it'll be like if he was just in prison
about anything else then I'll probably
give him a chance but like in general I
don't really hold people from what
they've done okay so they are now okay
so for high value women to you body
count doesn't matter if it's a thousand
you're cool
you're cool I wouldn't say I'm cool okay
okay
so yeah okay okay so what how how many
bodies she got to be under I'll say
probably
stay on the bike
20. okay under 20. she's high value yeah
okay what else and I'll say definitely
need to motivate me in some way I'll say
because I'm a gym person and I'll say
she's Health healthier okay yeah and
um high value
who's is there a woman you think of when
you think of a high value woman
someone in the media
but I'm just wondering I'm really
working my brain I'm just gonna yeah
yeah
um
not right now I wouldn't like choose a
specific one right now okay yeah what do
you think a thing I think with higher
value women it could mean different
things I think if a woman's got respect
she's kind she's honest
she's got like a business mentality and
she's hard working that to me so she's a
higher value because she's putting in
that extra effort and a lot I know a lot
of girls that sit around at home all day
don't do nothing with their life but
then you see a lot of women that work
their asses off you know and to me that
shows that they're trying to be good
women you know I don't think no no I
don't even really care no yeah it's like
it's like nothing to them okay okay it's
like it's like you know I have a guy who
talks about a shoe collection yeah and
yoga that's nice but I don't care oh
yeah okay yeah okay it's like our jobs
yeah I think I think it's hard because
everyone's got like a different Vision
in their head of how a woman should be
I'm just curious so okay so you said
she's gotta have respect like what what
what does she have to do to be a high
value woman like what skills does she
have to have
what what does she have to look like
well we all know a man likes a classy
woman right not all men but we all know
a man likes to collide him not someone
that shows their stuff on Instagram or
you know oh sorry does that sort of
thing so in my head a higher value woman
to a man is someone that dresses
appropriately okay and has morals okay
whatever that means to some people okay
but um the bar is low that's it I mean
that's all we got a deal my head is a
bit frazzled right now but so don't
sleep all right this is what I got so
far don't sleep with 20 people don't
have your butt on Instagram
shape
and ha be respectable yeah that's it
okay
I'm just repeating that I feel like
it'll come back to me that's okay okay
what do you think what is a high value
woman it doesn't exist because some
people don't believe in it so it's up to
you it has to exist
but it's completely different to what
makes a high value man I think
um women judge a high value Man based on
the things that we want and what we look
for so
um a high value woman has to be based on
what men are looking for which is going
to be completely different so it would
be younger women uh top 20 to 20.
in shape yeah not not got everything out
on Instagram and low body count once
kids wants family wants a husband
doesn't want to go out on uh girls
holidays
um all those kinds of things
to Beast okay what do you think no I
don't believe there's high value women I
believe value is contextual okay so it's
all very dependent on what you see at
the end of the day you could have a
woman who is what Society theme is
overweight and a man might value that
really highly because that's what he
wants it all depends on somebody's
experience so I don't believe there's
high value women I believe that there
are women who want to put out certain
ways about them and if that's what they
want to do then that's awesome and there
are women who are going to do what
they're going to do and men will still
idolize and worship them anyway that's
what I believe anyway
sorry can you explain that again so
value is contextual right so it depends
on how
someone will perceive that woman so
somebody might look at I don't know the
queen and see she's high value because
she's head of the monarchy and she owns
Windsor Castle and all the rest of it
some of us look at the queen and think I
can't stand it I don't like her at all
she's not high value to me okay whereas
somebody may look at somebody that lives
within a council estate and they may
aspire to be with a woman like that but
you don't think there's you don't think
there's like General things that most
met like most men might look at I don't
know Margot Robbie Beyonce 20 years ago
and say like the high value or good
looking like you don't think there's
General things that like men want good
look it doesn't mean high value though
somebody can there's loads of people
that are good looking it doesn't mean
that they're high value so at the end of
the day I'm just wondering if it starts
there at least for guys no so I can only
talk for myself but for me personally
looks doesn't necessarily then equate to
high value I've seen women that are what
people classify tens and their values
are -10 so at the end of the day to me
it's contextual very very content well
I'm not saying I'm not saying it's just
like I'm saying it's not looks alone but
like you that would start there like I
don't think you can be like 300 pounds
and be high value as a girl I just think
it doesn't it depends on who's looking I
know men that want 300 pound girls and
they deem them to be high value so it
just depends in my opinion I think
usually those guys can't get laid by
anyone else very true yeah you know I
just I don't see the rich man like
bringing the whales to functions you
know very very true but then we're not
looking at from a men's point of view
we're looking at from a women's point of
view so the question you asked was is
what do people deem to be a high value
so I'm not looking as a high value man
looking as a high value woman I'm just
looking at what a high value woman is
you know I was looking I was thinking of
it from the men's point of view because
I'm just looking at like the most sought
after men tend to pick which isn't like
fat chicks okay so if we're looking at
it from that way the most sought after
men no they wouldn't necessarily pick
that although some men have some really
crazy fetishes so they may say that they
don't want these women on the surface
but then what they're doing behind
closed doors is they've I mean every
King had concubines but it doesn't
matter her Queen you know no that's a
tool but he might deem that woman so the
high value woman might be the one that
he puts on a pedestal but then he might
be the woman that he's sleeping with
that's 300 pounds high value as well
because she's given him what he needs at
the time that he needs it so it's all
very yeah but I would think you'd have
like results to show you know what I
mean like you'd have like a ring or like
a house oh so some concubines have
rings they might but I just I don't
really see them bringing the the
concubines out in public like they're
usually in the back you know I agree
with that I agree with you don't yeah
they don't bring those concubines but
those concubines get to live in the
Ivory Tower yeah and they're quite happy
with it as well so yeah to me it's
contextual okay what do you think do
high value women exist yeah yeah have I
ever even how value women does exist uh
because uh like uh
yeah
the first time being a desert so they
gave it so after you know so what was
the question again all right so what is
a high value do high value women exist
and what is a high value woman so high
value woman is like a girl that got
herself put together like uh that go out
there every single day to work
um on what they love
and also like doesn't party all the time
and um
yeah that's what I got so is Oprah a
high value woman
no not really she does What She Likes
every day and I don't think she's a big
partyer she doesn't seem like it Oprah
high value no uh yeah but no at the same
time okay well I think yeah I forget I
forget and just some of you guys the bar
is like low but wow I don't really yeah
everything it's like with this everyone
here is a high value
like I think it depends though like
because it's like there's women out
there that works to separate himself
from the rest which is why I can
appreciate that you know I mean but
obviously
we all like humans we like what we like
but I believe like there is high value
women out there there is women that
really go out there and gets it they're
really put in the work to be taller yeah
yeah
um I guess like what you guys most of
you not you but are describing it's just
like it's very like a low bar like we
don't really got to do much you might be
right I'm I'm just asking the question
what do you think is there a high value
woman or do high-value women exist if so
who are they well so this is an
interesting question I pondered about
this a little bit too because there's a
lot of people that ask like oh you know
high value men so let's that's the other
side of it is the does the high value
Man exist right people like what's a
high value man well that's an easy
question to answer it's just a high
value man first of all who measures
value like we have to have an objective
standard we can't be delusional and be
like everybody likes different things
with you know if this grows into this
King then she's a high value woman it's
like is she high value because you're
into crapping in her mouth and she takes
it that makes her high value that's
absolutely crazy easy a kink doesn't
make a person high value it makes them a
sexual object I can buy a sexual object
and if I can buy it it's not going to be
a lot of value in the marketplace
because there's a lot of dudes that can
buy it so who determines value that's an
interesting question and the answer is
where it's the market that determines
the value like for people don't know
what that means it's like buy my house
for a billion dollars it's like but this
house sucks yeah but I determined my own
value it's a billion dollars how many
people buy that house
zero people who determines the value of
a house the market what does that mean
it's the Willing number of buyers that
are gonna pay the maximum price and the
highest bidder usually wins so the value
has to be determined by the highest
bidder that's how things work in life
right so a high value woman would be a
woman that is sought after by the
highest bidder the highest bidding net
now this is a really interesting
question because this is a actually a
really interesting discussion with a
friend of mine about this like what does
it mean to bet on a woman see this is
where women get confused right because
women are like oh a lot of guys want to
sleep with me on the idea me so I'm a
high value woman
but that's but that's a misnomer in the
in the value Marketplace and there's a
really easy answer for that right like
here's a question for you guys how many
people in the world today can go pay
cash and buy a Ferrari is that a lot or
a little hello it's a little how many
people can save up for a little bit and
uh rent a Ferrari for their wedding or
their graduation
quite a lot of people right so women are
like oh these dudes are hitting me I'm
High Valley it's like no you're a rental
car you know a lot of guys can save up
and rent a nice car for a day you're not
high value so a high value cannot be a
rental car a car value a high value has
to be an owner car so a high value Woman
by the definition of the market is just
what is the highest status or the
highest value or most desired because
that's how men's values Market it you
know what is the highest value man that
is willing to give you what
ring a ring there it is it's the highest
value man that's willing to give you a
ring so if you can get dudes that want
to hump you but they don't want to give
you a ring you're not high value and
that's that's the answer the high value
women exists yes because I'm married for
for 10 years with four kids
uh and I know a lot of other dudes that
are doing pretty darn well uh that are
married to these women
but then it goes back to what I was
saying before so it's contextual so
it's like I could say my mum's high
value but my mum's done a lot of stuff
that other people would have deemed to
be high value but my mom's high value
but she's worth something to me she's my
mum she raised me yes but we're talking
about sexual market value we're not
talking about do I love my mother it's a
totally different argument I get I get
that but where I come back is that what
you're saying is basically where I play
the nutshell's contextual so you can be
married so it's what you're saying is
that basically it's a woman who a man's
worth willing to put a ring on yeah a
man might be waiting to put a ring on
somebody that's 300 pounds so in no man
listen listen I know guys and I'm gonna
bring him to Pearl show on Saturday by
the way if you guys are going to watch I
hope it's going to be amazing I know
guys worth 100 million dollars like I
was with one just the other day at my
place and Henry was filming I was having
a conversation it's like no dude is like
I've made 100 million dollars now it's
time to bag me a 300 pounder and my and
my life is complete zero men not even
one man is thinking that you know I
think then again it's contextual because
I can go to my account I go to my place
of Heritage where I know a man who is
incredibly rich and his woman is over
250 pounds and that's his wife yeah and
he parades her everywhere and he's very
happy to do it and the concubines
Parade's probably the right word here
and the concubines that he has are women
who other men would be high value how
long have they been together 15 years
okay yeah but was she like that one he
like was was he Rich then he was rich
and he picked a fat and he's always
picked to women that are larger because
that's his thing so again it's
contextual but that's not market value
it's like yeah some some guys like you
know a shitty car that breaks down
because they're into this vintage shitty
car but that's not that's not the market
value that's just the guy right you're
applying group statistics to an
individual which is fine and I agree
with your argument you're like well my
mom is high value because she does a lot
of good things for me you know my kid
her kids Society Etc I get that
obviously in the context of the show
we're talking about sexual market value
right now if a guy likes a uh if a guy
likes a whale let me say this that's a
terrible strategy for a woman to implore
in her life like well some guys like me
if I'm 300 pounds it's like
yeah but that's not maximizing for
Success yeah that's true that's you're
at that point you're just a disabled
parking spot right like guys will park
with you but they'll check if anyone's
looking first
that's the point would you if you had do
you have kids yeah they've got a
daughter yeah if you were going to give
her advice
just generally because if you've got a
son you tend to give your kids advice on
how to grow up and be a good man how
if you were to advise your daughter your
recommendation wouldn't probably be to
yeah just get as fat as you like because
some man out there will love you you
kind of
you want your child to kind of aim
you know yeah do you know I think of
getting a good man I know my viewpoints
are very different to most people so
like we could look at things
holistically like of course we can we
can look at things holistically look at
it and at the end of the day right and
we have to on a show yeah because like
on a show it's not about individuals
like we're talking about Society in
general
um what do you think high value woman I
definitely exist yeah and from like
listening to everybody I like I'd list
the looks body count probably important
uh for me intelligence definitely high
up there
uh loyalty is a big deal and nurturing
for sure if I would list a few things
um how
bodies
girl have to have for how for how you to
go off the table
so she no longer it's yeah I know you
said 20. it's got a generous man over
here uh what do you think
[Music]
um
whatever the guy thinks like whatever
I'm asking what you think
personally for me I feel like
body count shouldn't matter but I feel
like if there was a number
I don't want to say because like I have
friends with higher body count you know
I don't want to like yeah I mean High
values it's supposed to it's like it's
like saying I'm not a millionaire not
everyone can be a millionaire not every
girl can be high value it's not an
insult if I say to you you're not a
millionaire you insulted
no so if I say you're not a high value
woman it should be insulting
I honestly don't know like I feel like
every man has their own like like he
said 20 like some guy some guys don't
care about body count okay I know but
I'm asking what you think okay what
about you and a brother
okay so for his girlfriend what's the
most
um
I'm not sure but I'm thinking the same
like 20 as well all right 20. okay what
do you think
I don't think body count matters one bit
because we're all born with
you know
private parts and stuff and they're
there to be used if you want to do that
of 100 people a week do that it's there
for a reason it's theirs to be pleased
on both ends and I just don't think
we're in a generation now we're really
body count like no why are you nodding
oh my God this is what I mean this is
what I mean it's different for everyone
I'm Gonna Give You stats I'm just
curious if it'll change your opinion so
so a girl if she's a virgin on her
wedding night 80 chance of a happy
marriage if she sleeps with more than
five people do you know what it drops
down to
very low 20 yeah so so knowing that you
don't think that it would be better for
a guy to pick a girl that is an 80
chance of a happy marriage and that
would make her more valuable definitely
girl that's love with 100 100 people
that's like every I don't even know
this is an example
um
I'll guess when you put it like that you
found 20 dudes you couldn't keep you
couldn't keep one at a time but you know
what though I'm doing like quite a lot
of people where they they don't want
anything serious and they lack doing
that and they actually enjoy it and
maybe it doesn't make them higher value
but if that's what someone enjoys go do
it
oh yeah like so first of all notice that
these girls are actually arguing against
each other but they don't realize it
right because this young lady here she's
like I don't want to say a number
because I have friends above that number
are you insinuating that being above
that number is going to be somehow
offensive to your friends like you're
literally saying with saying that that
well High number is bad my friends will
feel bad about themselves and I'll make
them look bad well if numbers don't
matter wouldn't they can just not care
just tell us what's that number tell us
how many how many bodies is too much so
that your friends aren't going to get
offended because your friend here said
that it doesn't matter does it no I I I
I agree with her like I feel like body
count shouldn't matter but I'm saying
like and yet you won't tell us
yeah you said well my friends are going
to get offended because they've had more
bodies are you insinuating that more
bodies is bad because that's what it
sounds like no really then tell us
what's that number
like I said like 20 things but like no
because she said if my brother was to
marry someone like what what would his
like body count would be with that woman
so I wouldn't know
but I feel like body count shouldn't
matter like like I said a guy cares
about a woman's Pastor how many
um guys they slept with but did she not
did I hear her wrong correct me guys if
I'm wrong did she not say five minutes
ago she said that I don't want to say a
number because my friends might be
offended because their numbers are
higher does that insinuate that a higher
number is bad by her trying to protect
her friends then yeah so she's arguing
against herself now let me tell you why
these girls are saying it you guys
understand why women say that body
numbers don't matter but they actually
think they do women are insinuating that
it's good to have an open sexual
Marketplace because they know that high
number of Partners discounts and
disvalues other women so they're like
you go girl you get that D you get
whatever you want blah blah blah but in
their heads yeah because if everyone was
right if everyone was a virgin the girls
that weren't it would like they would be
way less value yes so that's like that
man should raise their stance it's the
same it's the same thing that women are
like oh you go you're 300 pounds lizzo
you're beautiful it's like they don't
but the women themselves don't believe
me men do this too I think men do this
too they don't want the market to change
and they don't want to like discount
no yeah they're trying to get laid so
they're like yeah we don't care about
the high body count for the night right
for the night but later they'll care
they'll care no offense no it's not just
you no
but like come on sir are you gonna you
want a girl that slept with with 20
dudes really that's your mother of your
kids that's your that's your wifey you
know she slept with Tom Dick Harry
Jeremy Tyrone Alex
Ryan Austin Adam
um
[Music]
Dimitri
um
and she'll never forget it yeah sorry
I'm not even I couldn't even think of 20
names but it's because you guys are
making it like
but it's like
let's see you would think of it
for me
Tyrone two
I'm almost you know oh you always wrote
it out yeah yeah I see it I can't even
give some nerdy names Philip Phillips
Jeff
and you're like you know what baby
that's all right
yeah I'm so happy to walk you down the
side in the white dress in front of the
whole crowd of people we know Five Guys
she slept with is in the crowd yeah the
is it's different though because like
thinking about it logically
thinking about it it will be like
I would if I know the person like deeply
enough like that wouldn't care but
initially going
to find someone I would prefer someone
that's like
below like five or something you know
what I mean thank you for being here yes
thank you for being honest but if I have
to like she could get away with 20 if
you had to if I but if you had two women
exactly the same one's 21 you're gonna
yeah yeah yeah yeah
thank you for being honest I knew I
would get it out of you I knew I would
it's okay he's young he's young it's not
as young though it's like
you know there's less guys been there
you know you feel somewhat more like
yeah cool like well it makes you feel
more secure in yourself I wouldn't say
secure it would be like all right less
guys as
touch her you know I mean like she's
like my precious she just said something
really interesting and I think that's
worth noting she said it makes you feel
more secure about yourself and that's a
gas lighting technique and if you want I
can really dig into this one yeah go
ahead because because she's saying like
well if you've you know with a woman
that has had less Partners it means that
you know you're just insecure being with
a woman with a very high body count
right but that's actually
Shifting the blame and the
accountability of your behavior on him
it's not his behavior that caused that
right now biologically men are
predisposed to do what to reproduce and
for that we need to have a paternity
guarantee that's why that's why we want
that's why virgins are very highly
valued through history we want to
guarantee if paternity want to make sure
the kids are our kids right and we know
that after what the five Partners pair
bonding basically drops and that's a
vasopressin chemical thing that's the
biggest drop is from um like one to two
yes it's like it's like 80 percent it
depends on then after five it starts to
drop again yeah yeah no five is like
it's like no like gone you know gone
forever but like one to two it goes from
like 80 to like 40 yeah so it's like so
it's like yeah you're insecure because
you wouldn't take a trick with a high
body count that just sounds like a chick
with a high body count doesn't wanna
doesn't want to take accountability for
her actions but as a man we know the
pair bonding decreases with a woman that
has a high body count we also know
there's a significantly higher
opportunity or actually a chance for her
to cheat because when women cheat if you
actually look at like at the data who
they cheat with it's usually somebody
they slept with in the past there's a
she's an alpha Widow of course yeah
really that makes perfect yeah of course
where did you find that I didn't ever
I've never oh yeah we can get into that
I got some books you can read right
because it's like a woman for her to
start a new relationship with a man
she's not doing it for the sex she's
doing it to leave the relationship women
cheat to leave relationships there's a
lot of data to actually back it up right
okay the data to back it up is very
simple a woman's propensity to cheat
drops significantly with the income of
her partner the Richer her husband the
Lesser woman cheats and this has been
proven over and over and over and over
and over most of the cheating there's
about 20 percent of women that are you
know statistically trying to be cheating
in their marriages
overwhelmingly those are sway towards
men that are earning below average
incomes versus men with higher incomes
tend to cheat more but their wives tend
to cheat significantly less so why do
women cheat
acquisition of resources why do men
cheat spread the seed paternity right
because men have more opportunities at
the higher income so it's like well you
don't want a woman with low body counts
because you're insecuring yourself no
that you're insecure in yourself and you
want to blame the man for it and that's
just like a really toxic Behavior
and if you think when you want to buy a
car or you want to buy clothes or
anything you want it not used really
yeah I don't want nobody putting dicks
in my car
uh what do you so do you still think
body count doesn't matter or do yeah you
still same opinion same opinion
I'm just curious like new new
information doesn't ever change it's
just I don't care I just don't care like
it just doesn't because for a man a man
can sleep with what a thousand people
but that man's not a hoe but a woman
she's a hoe hey he's the Homemaker he's
like okay he's a homemaker but um I mean
what's the phrase like a key that opens
many locks is a good key but but a lot
of it opens for everybody it's not a
good luck no also you have to let the
men actually in yeah do you know what I
mean yeah it's quite actually a big deal
yeah I guess so it should be and you
know what actually saying you're saying
that I do understand because it's like a
soul Tire a little bit I feel like if
you do sleep around you're kind of
letting people into your less that's
your home you know your body is your
home so I do understand that as well
likely to pass on like St yeah
like one in one in four women have an
STD actively oh God
yeah one in three women have had an
abortion too it's like actually crazy
the numbers
what's like guys like girls are
experience and it's like
so okay
we just went oh why are you going back
to the world
okay you know what you you this is the
problem
men like you this is what you guys do
you're trying to not you don't want the
you know the women you want to sleep
with or whatever to let you hear you
hear you saying that because you you're
no come on but you know
so then you mislead us it's misleading
to women because you tell women it
doesn't matter and then the women say oh
okay it doesn't matter they'll go do it
but you know it matters so let's we're
not Liars on this one tellers it's
confusing though it's like guys like I
think guys will be more likely to keep a
goat if they're like sexually satisfied
with that woman you know and I think
girls that's had like a lot of
experience can provide that for guys but
I don't know can you provide it for hers
the question too can I provide it not
sarcastically by the way because you
don't know the emotional the emotional
engagement she had previously it's not
even about the sex it's about the danger
of the sex how would you forbiddedness
of it right how would you feel if you
got like a woman with like a high body
count like well I can tell you exactly
how I felt I was dating a girl in Texas
and I've said this on a podcast once
before and she was like super hot and I
was just like wow and I was younger at
the time too so I was like I really
valued that as like the number one thing
yeah and then and then you know a couple
of months in the relationship you had to
have a conversation she was like Hey I
just need you to know like I I didn't
know this I was very naive she's like
I'm I'm a stripper I actually had no
idea I just remember thinking the whole
time I was like this chick's out of body
she should be a stripper right she was a
stripper and then we went to a certain
um we went to a sporting event and there
were 10 athletes on the on playing and
she had slept with eight of them and she
told me that she's like I slept with
this guy and this guy this is one of
those girls that would hunt those kind
of professional athletes right yeah and
I was just like oh I think my dog just
fell off because I was like I don't
think I wanna you know I don't think I
wanna I don't know if it's a competition
thing but like hey no future what was
her body uh I don't know the exact
number but when you're there's 10 guys
on the court and she's been with eight
of them yeah of the ten yeah but yeah
she had to have been like if you even
found out about eight I'd be like 50 or
something oh that was way more than that
I'm sure I'm sure it was what I guess
she she actually kept a list of all the
famous dude she was with like don't get
me wrong the SEC the sex was just like
mind-blowing fine but I'm thinking like
there's no way I would have a daughter
with this person there's like a 50 50
roughly chance that one of her is like
on the whole way no way was like imagine
day in for like
might even dating saying you've known
this girl for like six years you thought
the world of hurt right and then all of
a sudden like after like six or seven
years you found out about account would
you look at that person differently or
would he just be like oh yes are you
just dating her for six years I say like
you're married or anything like even
say even like she's your girlfriend
right
and you've known her for six years this
is like has that happened to you no okay
so six years it's very specific
yeah but it's like after so long would
you look at that person differently
knowing that oh what it comes like 50 or
something you know you would there's no
way in hell that you wouldn't that you
would you may not say anything but in
the back of your mind you're gonna be
thinking oh my God she's slept with that
many men and then you're now going to
start looking at a differently so what
then tends to happen is that you might
now she might say I'm going to have my
friends so when she was doing it before
you're fine but when she's now doing it
and she's told you a number you're
thinking oh is
where are you going particularly like
what are you gonna do yep it's an ego
thing yeah I get it you know I don't see
you asleep
that's a secret that's quite a secret to
her I'm just thinking 50 met with you
you can't could you go anywhere run it
like is this like the law of something
where you're like five connections away
from everybody is that a thing yeah it
is yeah
so I'm like a 50. did you guys run into
like like men she slept with well we
would we would go to sporting events and
see them playing sports so that was like
kind of weird and you know it's always
the same conversation it's like oh now
that you know like you don't think it's
highly of me cry cry I'm like no no no
it's fine I don't care about your past
of course I'm gonna say it because I
want more mind-blowing sucks but I'm not
gonna put a ring on it because remember
market value is not determined but how
long did you date her for about six
seven months okay and then you broke it
off
um she'd reappear occasionally in my
life since then I mean up until like you
know up until I got very serious with
somebody right you know it was business
is business
you could have dated her for six years
her thinking you're gonna marry her you
knowing that you would I wasn't gonna do
that I know but I'm just saying women
don't realize that a man can date you
for years and have absolutely no
intention of marrying you he's just
waiting until he finds that woman that
he will marry and we don't really know
that but that's true women women do the
same they do and I think they're signs
anyway I don't think I think that's
that's weird you're describing hypergamy
that's actually very female Behavior
women no no I mean
no I don't mean that
yeah
I actually agree with him because women
leave more we leave like 80 of the time
I don't mean leaving I just mean that a
man have you not had boyfriends that now
you look back you think actually I
thought I broke up with him but he was
never gonna marry me you weren't you
weren't you weren't his girlfriend you
just learned that they weren't your
boyfriend oh
it's like if if a woman is giving up
like oh we're dating but it's like well
are you dating or are you right no I've
only ever had like relationship well
I've had a situation [__] but you know
what I mean is
you might think as a girl that you're
dating this guy and you may even live
together but
that still doesn't mean he has any
intention of actually marrying you and
you don't know that that's what happened
to you
not what like the the dating someone for
a long time and he had known I've had
several relationships that now I look
back I think actually that was never
going anywhere either I always thought
it was me deciding that but then you
think actually he never was gonna
propose anything it was time wasting men
can waste time yeah did he did he end up
like marrying someone else right after
or did they never get married
um a couple of my exes I think are
married Yeah
because sometimes I think it's like
girls will try to make a guy that
doesn't want to be a husband a husband
yeah I mean he's just not a husband so I
was just curious if the guys like were
they not husbands or like they were
never gonna marry you to me they weren't
I don't actually think they were
husbands I wasn't happy but
they may well be now this was obviously
I'm 35 this was in my 20s early 20s
um
I think that women date potential so me
dating someone at my own age at that
point might have been the problem I've
I've not really dated older I've not
really I've been a bit weird about it
but actually maybe that's a better idea
not now my my fiance's younger but
I'm just saying that uh
do you know if a guy doesn't get married
after the age of 35 he only has a 15
chance of ever getting married not crazy
for women it's like zero percent oh wow
no I think what is it by if a woman
doesn't if a woman doesn't have a child
by 35 the chances of her having a child
drop to about zero well she's single by
30 the chance of her the chance if she's
single at 30 the chance of her ever
having like a kid drops below 50 right
so like she's more likely to not have a
kid than have one what does that tell
you about sexual market value of a woman
that's a scary statistic right that's a
harsh reality for me I'm getting married
I would like to have kids my partner
would like to have kids but I am 35 and
the chances and I think that should be
taught to to girls because at the moment
you see a lot of celebrities they've
played for IVF they've had their Expos
and they're doing it older but they've
got millions of pounds to achieve things
that isn't actually easy to achieve in
the real world what do you wish you knew
at 25
uh not to date anybody for potent for
their potential because the chances of
them fulfilling that potential are quite
slim
um that actually a man who is a
go-getter a man that is a hard worker
driven they already are and it's not
going to come from me pushing them they
already are that person and then yeah
would you say you dated more for like
looks in your 20s
not based on my exes no but I I do think
that that's what you look for definitely
um but I've
I've
sort of
oh sorry me
this way sorry it's because I'm looking
at Power that's why
um
forgiveness me
I lost where I was again I asked if you
you dated for looks in your 20s because
you said not based on my exes no but I
do think that
uh Charisma I'd say I went for the funny
one the loud one the blue one you know
they weren't always the best looking one
but but I think that that comes off as
like a masculinity in a way so I think
that's what I was attracted to
um and then I'd get in the relationship
and realize actually they weren't doing
anything else and I stood Your Hooks
they had a lot of practice to get that
funny a lot of free time exactly yeah
yeah yeah yeah okay
um what did you think of the body count
uh when does is high value off the table
for a woman I think it is uh slightly
age-related as well
um I think that if I had a kid or a
niece well I do have a niece I would say
just hold on to your virginity for as
long as you can
um but I think that early 18 if you
start having sex when you're 16 maybe
you've slept with one person and then 20
maybe two you know and then if you're 35
and you've had a few relationships and
it'll be a little bit above but I think
that there's no need to to go out
yeah I think what's the what's the
number oh sorry yeah I'm sorry
uh so
early 20s I'd say like five okay what
are you just high value off the table
for a woman probably 25. okay so so five
then okay roughly five five twenty five
yeah I know you got it uh what do you
think yeah I think five five yeah after
five high values off the table it's
finished I'll see you guys sorry
I'll say below double digits to be
honest below okay you're kind of time
that's the most common answer I get I
get like yeah 10 is well I I get when I
ask how many bodies is Too Many Bodies
it's always prefer five I'll deal with
ten fifteen maybe if she's hot yeah
what do you think
well it's funny that a lot of people
land on five that's like statistically
kind of the average for women in the
western Nations like and so you're kind
of going well as long as she's kind of
average which is you know I think it's a
fair standard average now that is about
the average yeah reported I mean
obviously there's going to be some
variances because people lie whatever
but on the grand scale it's probably not
off by more than one the one I the one I
read was higher than that it was like
eight I think that might have been like
Sweden or something like a really like
egalitarian sort of open society that
could happen for me you know so and uh
were you doing like world yeah okay no
it's more Western world it's more like
England America Canada you know like
sort of like the G20 whatever you want
to call it so there there could be you
know some variance in that but
that's good though if the average is
five it's a it's such a it's such an
interesting thing let me tell you guys
this like here's a question I would ask
right and here's a like a legitimate
statistical question I'm interested in
this right
as a man's income and options go up
options meaning more women are willing
to sleep with them therefore he gets to
choose who he wants to commit to because
that's what a man does at the end of
high value he chooses we commits to
right he's the one that controls the
commitment the woman controls the sex
right as the man's options go up does
that number change
an interesting question because like
the the body count for a girl that's
acceptable to him to form a long-term
relationship like I know a dude we
actually both know a dude with Henry
that like is with the check right now
and like you can tell she's been with a
lot of dudes but the guy's so
inexperienced and naive he's just happy
to have a woman he's like yeah I have a
woman is he well off or no no no no no
no no not at all but I'm thinking like
but I'm thinking like if this guy was
like as this guy right he's young but as
he rises through life he's like you know
makes more money more money more so
whatever that metric you use for Value
whatever whatever you know gains more
opportunity more more social value
he might look at that chick and be like
you know what I can do better
you know be it's like the same that your
friend is picking up a 300 pound check
it's like most of the guys that go for
that by the way there's actual studies
on this as well right and they say that
poorer men prefer fatter women and I
look at that study ago it's not that
they prefer it's just who they can get
it's just like the market has a certain
equilibrium right there's a surplus so
that there's way too many chicks that
are oversized and there's way too many
lazy broke ass dudes and then the market
Surplus adjusts itself they're really a
match made in heaven Heaven's a strong
word
Heaven's a strong word but that's funny
because this lady in the green dress
here was saying like yeah I had some
guys living with me that never really
thought they were going to marry me and
my first thought was like I wonder if
they're a very low ambition men
yeah because they're comfortable being
in an imperfect situation what happens
is in this young gentleman here in front
of me in the matching suit he was saying
earlier he's like I want a girl that
that pushes me to and motivates me and
I'm like no you don't if a woman has to
motivate you if no you don't if a woman
has to encourages you then if a woman
has to motivate you in a relationship
you will both be better and resentful
encourages I agree with that yeah like
like my woman is like hey do you need to
travel on that trip do you do this I'm
like yeah like you know like I I told my
girlfriend who became my wife I was like
I'm really really ambitious gonna be
working all the time you have to deal
with that if you don't that's okay but
that's gonna be me and so and I find
that her attraction for me uh stabilizes
and even goes up because I am achieving
new things all the time and and she
won't deny that I agree with that
completely I work six days seven days a
week and you have to put up with it it's
just that's what I do and I'm not gonna
stop doing what I'm doing because I'm
able to provide what I need to provide
and no matter what arguments happen
you're still happy with what I'm doing
because it shows that I'm doing what I
need to do I would ask an interesting
question anybody here grow up with a
two-parent household like my parents
were together for mostly most of my life
okay and I experienced this right like
my mom was constantly
um frustrated and a little resentful at
my dad because he wasn't as ambitious as
she was has anybody ever experienced
that that's a terrible relief I saw that
as a kid that's a terrible no that's a
bad relationship to observe that's a bad
relationship because what happens Pearl
you know that's what happens with the
moment a woman out earns a man she
leaves it's done done yeah instantly so
it's like you want to really motivate
your guy no you don't support him no but
that's yeah might support oh why not the
guy should have his own drive his own
ambition his own motivation he should
have his own goals and then the woman's
like yeah you go yeah yeah positivity at
home not you know not actually because I
made the mistake of thinking that I
could motivate people that don't have
any motivation any drive any girls and
they're happy to win and not very but
that guy won't choose a 300 pound woman
with 20 ducks like he just won't here
why would why why would
he agree with what you're saying as well
so you know it's interesting it's like
women we pick non-monogamy in our 20s
like so it's like interesting because
this is the first time in human history
where women have been in control of sex
like historically you either go with the
guy that steals you you know what I mean
or or you're dead you can fly with him
so this is the first time in human
history we're 100 in control of sex
because there's consequences for the men
and we're also 100 in control of who's
born so what happened you would think
like when women were in control of sex
that we would pick monogamy right but
it's interesting because women when we
are at our Peak like we're in our Prime
we pick non-monogamy in our 20s and
typically like women pick non-monogamy
because we're going we find 80 of men is
unattractive not just okay not just nah
we find them as ugly so because we find
80 of them is unattractive that means
we're sharing 20 of men and so yeah so
we're picking and because in our 20s
like you were saying like you can't pick
a guy for ambition like maybe it's
social status whatever it is
um so basically women share women men in
their 20s and then their 30s pick a
leftover guy typically that they
wouldn't have picked in their 20s I am
yeah I agree with it as well same yeah
they agree with that you always see the
age of things like when I was in school
you get the really
Chris looking God everyone wanted and
she would only pick who she deemed to be
really handsome or whatever it was and
then as she got into a 30s had three or
four children and body shapes now no
longer the same all of a sudden because
for me I truly believe that men as they
get older they become more attractive
that's just there's a reason they age
like found wine that's a phrase women
age like milk yeah
even even with the botox nowadays we
could see your forehead not moving
it looks so shiny as well so then you
get those with me in their early 20s who
didn't necessarily in a pic you know all
of a sudden they want to pick you win
but I don't they're in a situation where
it's like oh you come back and say yeah
because I mean they don't have as much
bargaining power it's like you got to go
half off yeah you know what I mean and
so now it's like they right we will run
to the guys that we rejected in our 20s
and her 30s and say take me with you
know and guess who they're gonna cheat
on you with those the guys that they
hooked up with their 20s exactly so
they're going right back yep yeah
um which which I I think that's like why
we really talk about what we do it's not
really to [__] on women but it's like a
lot of men are naive to this they think
oh she really likes me because she's
coming in in my 30s or maybe she just
overlooked me in high school but she
never look you she's just you know the
other guys didn't work out your second
choice see they just don't know she'd
bet against you yeah and you let her
back in you're in trouble yeah
that's it's harsh I don't I think that
women some women just make a lot of
mistakes and are looking in the wrong
way because I'm like I'm a relationship
person I wasn't just like you know going
all around the place but
um
what's high value when you're younger it
or what you think is how I value when
you're younger isn't what you're not
kind of linking it to a husband yeah you
know you're not hunting you're right
you're right because when women get
closer to 30 it's like they look more
for long-term security so in their 20s
it goes back to what we were saying it
tends to be looks more like Prime jeans
so they may say okay these guys are the
ideal genes that I want for for whatever
reason maybe it's social status maybe
whatever but then in their 30s they tend
to go from like long-term security and
like safety and so you know basically
it's like Alpha Beta like they pick the
alphas in their 20s and the betas in
their 30s yeah and women don't typically
respect the B I mean I hate the word
Alpha and beta but you understand what
I'm saying
and you don't realize as well that um
when you're saying the bait is like at
say at school at College whatever just
the good looking guy is the one that all
the girls want but you don't realize
these guys over here are the ones that
are going to make the money have their
own businesses and you're not that's
just not in your head at all you just
want
it's an attraction it's not you're not
thinking it through if you see what I
mean it's not like a decision you've
made on purpose well there's a reason
historically like the dads would keep
their daughters away from certain guys
like this is why that's a problem no
that's why women like we suck at
relationships we don't pick the right
guys in general because this is the
first time because in the 20s it
switched where women used to live with
their uh their dad and then they went
straight to their husbands so there was
no period it like in between and so that
in the 20s that was when women started
to go out you know that's why they say
the Roaring 20s they started going to
the parties you know they cut their hair
off all this wild stuff and so that was
the first time where women were more in
control of sex and More in control of
who they were picking and that's when
you start to see the Burt like women
having less children and that's when you
well you see the divorce rate more go
down in 65 when women were 100 in
control of of reproduction because we
got in birth control
but my whole point is that when women
are in charge we make bad choices we're
not children yeah they give us too much
Freedom we don't know what we're doing
yeah if my dad had chosen who I dated I
wouldn't have dated any of them in my
20s really you know and that's the thing
like a lot of times girls will say to me
I don't say it to be mean but they'll
say oh uh well not all women are like
that and then I'll ask them like
follow-up questions about their exes in
their 20s like did you did your parents
like them the answer is always no you
know those were funny a couple of them
were funny or nice or yeah or yeah or if
the parents did like them she left him
yeah so you know so there's there's
people can be likable and not sorry not
Dependable husband for other material
yeah correct and the parents see that
yeah and then we just say la la la la la
don't hear you I pick them anywhere yeah
well you just unpacked something really
interesting for a lot of guys listening
to this you need to be really careful
about this you're like well you know we
were I was in my 20s and picking guys
that weren't like a good long-term you
know secure option I was picking like
this thing they got me was really what
they did is they got you sexually
excited that's what it was I was there
was passion and there was some
attraction there's Charisma there's that
you know that's exactly what it was and
then you get and now you're like well I
wasn't thinking about this like
longevity and this and it's like what do
you mean you weren't thinking about it I
I know what it means I mean let me say
what what it means is now you're
thinking about it and so now you're
having as a woman and this is like not
you specifically but in general women
get to 30 31 32 it's like oh now I have
to think about these things which means
you're rationalizing yourself into a
relationship and the question I would
have is is rationalizing yourself into a
relationship genuine desire now you do
misunderstand me a little bit I've
always always wanted to get married and
have kids and I've always been thinking
oh yeah I'll marry this person without
thinking what does he earn what
potential does he have to earn anymore
does he even want to earn anymore he
smokes I don't even like smoking why
would I marry someone that's my it's the
worst thing in the world I you know what
I mean they've done drugs well that's
like I hate it and I and for me it's a
passion so I'm trying to accept things
that I don't accept and trying to make
this person into something instead of
finding a man that is already
he's saying like again
I know exactly what it means and you
can't and you couldn't say it if you did
so it doesn't matter that you would
never say I wouldn't settle for my
partner you wouldn't say the opposite so
that we can't trust those words even
though they're probably I want you to be
right but we can't trust them it's like
well you know I wouldn't speak badly
with my husband no [__] you wouldn't
obviously you wouldn't so that's fine
but the reality is you get you know
women get to a certain age and they
start looking these other attributes but
that's not genuine desire right and so
what happens is when she marries that
guy where was that genuine design in the
20s it's still for those guys and by the
way coming back to this where did she go
back to for that genuine desire no but
sexual desire isn't what gonna is gonna
keep you in a relationship but it'll
make you cheat
but it'll make you cheat and that's you
know it doesn't mean that you don't
sexually desire the partner that you've
checked because it sure doesn't but it
doesn't lock out and find somebody who
is all of the things that you do you're
100 you're 100 correct but so the
chances of it are very slim though I got
a friend he's worth about 120 million
dollars uh he's 42 and he's single he's
a great guy I'm real tight with this guy
but he's single he's 42 and he flies all
the time around the world he tells me
he's like I'm bringing this girl and
trip with me I'm bringing that girl a
trip with me that's what these guys do
when they're 100 million you know before
they're 40. they just fly around the
world and take girls with them in
different places right makes sense and
he's like oh I'm taking this chick but
she's married
I'm like what she's he's like yeah we
used to hook up like you know six seven
years ago and then she got married but
you know how it goes and I'm like what
do you mean he's like well you know
she's married some guy he's a
construction guy he's a nice guy but he
can't take her to Dubai for a week and I
can so she just says she's got a work
trip and she just goes and meets with me
and I'm like dude is that normal he's
like
he's like yeah like every chick I hooked
up with in my 30s Doug got married is
now like lighting me up on Insta like
hey what you do and haven't you know
thought about you for a while and and
I'm like so what does that teach you sir
about you know the dating Marketplace he
goes I wouldn't and he's 42 now he goes
I would never marry a woman in her 30s
why because I know that she's not
marrying me for the genuine desire at
this point she just wants to settle down
now that might be an extreme argument to
look at it and I understand that group
statistics don't apply to an individual
but that's a scary thing to think about
and so I'm like so who are you going to
marry you're 42. he's like
um you know he's like I think if I get
married it'll be an amino girl 22 23.
it's a big age Gap but he's like but
he's got 120 mil he's got the life like
he's got women available to him at that
option he doesn't have to deal with the
history that's his biggest fear is
during dealing with the history I will
agree actually so if I met my partner at
work and it literally seriously lucked
out but before that when I was looking
on Tinder you've got divorces you've got
dads I don't want to be with somebody
that's got kids already that aren't you
know that you've got slim pickings at 35
34 so in that case I can see that a lot
of women would probably settle or no I
mean yeah but you also you can also see
why from a guy's point of view it's like
risky with a girl that's older because
it's like more baggage that he has to
deal with yeah more guys that he that he
really has to compete with at Rolo
tomasi has a phrase It's not the number
but it's like the number of like Alphas
or okay I'm butchering this please
but it's basically like the number of
high value guys that she's been with
because if she's been with Drake
um I don't know the CEO of Budweiser
like how how is you know Tom Dick or
Harry gonna compete
yeah you know she's always gonna feel
like she's settled and nobody wants to
feel like they settled in a relationship
but men can live with it women can't I
think anyway do you think that's true
well one thing that I that I really I'm
very passionate about like in our
business uh we're in the suit selling
business but really we recruit and hire
young men uh and and my pitch is very
simple I hire young men and teach them
how to make a million dollars a year
that's what I do in my business right uh
our company you know offices of 27
countries across the world uh most of
the guys that work with us are in their
early to mid 20s when they start we
teach them how to build value and I tell
the guys this I'm like don't get married
in your 20s they go what I'm like you're
going to be working 80 hours a week with
us just commit to that work 80 hours a
week and when you're not working go to
the gym why because by the time you get
to 27 28 30 you're going to have a lot
of money and a lot of muscles and then
you can live the life that you want and
that's what I teach that's like the the
sort of what this conversation
cultivates to is like yeah we can talk
about what's a high value woman but the
deeper question is
how does a man get a high value woman
because there is such a thing as a hobby
so how do you get that so I want to ask
you girls what do you think how does a
man get a high value if you think you're
a high value woman how does a man get
you and don't say lazy and funny
I think definitely every man should go
to the gym because that's the first
thing a woman looks at you don't even
have to be particularly good looking but
if you're fit and you've got you look
like you can protect someone you've got
presents in a room then that works
straight away and then if you have to be
more than that so if you're funny it
helps if you've got Charisma if you've
got a good job if you've got Drive
um and then
I think the soft nice stuff actually
probably comes last or the cuddly I
think women can live without that I
think you need it a bit but
I think when men start with that and
that you know you go out with the nice
guy and it gets you flowers but he's not
strong and he's not driven and he's not
it kind of makes you feel a bit sickly
that they get you the flowers and
they're nice to you all the time it's
kind of too much yeah honestly and like
that sounds but that's why nice guys
don't get the girls because that they
because they have nothing else to
compete on it's because it's the easiest
thing to to project but it doesn't
require sacrifice but it's not that
because I was thinking earlier that if
those guys just went to the gym and got
a bit more presents that's easier than
trying to get those guys to be nice and
lovely and you know and
potentially commit so you know we always
go for those guys hoping that they're
going to choose us when actually they
can choose from so many women and they
don't care and they don't have any rush
to settle down why are they going to do
that for us
as opposed to so the nicer guys if you
get a guy in the middle that's kind of
like a five across the board he can kind
of like boost up a bit and that that
that's good
what do you think I think if I see
my man treat his mum with respect you
know treat treat his the women in his
family how they should be treated
because I've seen a lot of guys and they
they're horrible to their parents who is
your last boyfriend
three years ago my only boyfriend okay
was he nice to his mom
yeah very nice who rounded the
relationship
um me
so it looks like they said listen to
what women do
but why he was nice to his mom yeah he
was nice to his mum but he also liked to
do a lot of really bad things so that
didn't do it for me but that is
definitely a big thing though still the
parents um looking at hygiene so you
want to be nice to your mother and
shower all right hi Jean
um for me I like a man with money
gonna say it because I need to feel
stable as well you know and women like
to be looked after I appreciate the
honestyles
and I feel like
it's where how much
give me your number a lot so I've been
single for quite a while now and I feel
like I'm looking after myself all the
time it gets to a point you get fed up
with that and you actually just want a
nice masculine man to take care of you
and put you in these arms I like that
and everyone's different but that's what
give me a number how much does he have
to make
how much
as long as I've got a nice house I've
got a nice car what is what does a nice
house go for in London oh I wouldn't
live in England anyway I'd live abroad
definitely all right so you're looking
for a man in another country no that
would want to move so hopefully he's got
his businesses all settled and we can go
what makes you think that guy will
choose you an interesting question you
know what I might never get a rich man
in my life but that's what I like so
hopefully it get there but okay I might
never get there I'm taking steps to get
there at the moment I'm healing on
myself I've got a lot of issues I need
to sort out before I can ever get a
partner okay and that's how are you
healing them therapy oh okay yeah I
think therapy makes you crazier no you
know what I think all the women I know
that go to therapy get worse yeah and I
can actually agree with that but the
only reason I'm getting this therapy
because it's free at the moment and I do
actually need some sort of help so is it
a male or a female it's a female I'm
gonna just you should go to a male
therapist really yeah women shouldn't be
therapist that's just my opinion I mean
I'm in the psychology program at the
school I promise you these women that
are giving you they're horrible yeah
horrible they're insane men look to
solve problems so a guy's going to tell
you if I have this problem so that you
solve it women are just going to say oh
it's okay tell me about your trauma well
it looks like I have had a men
therapists that have made me feel really
uncomfortable and flirt with me and that
didn't solve any of my problems well I
felt uncomfortable at my therapy session
so to me I'll feel more comfortable
woman how do you flirt
just making comments what's your social
media and things like that you know
making me feel uncomfortable because
everyone he knew that I'm a essay no SW
a sex worker W yeah do you think that
helps or hurts with your mental health
it hurts it so so much okay I'll be so
real or can you why do you keep doing it
then because at that moment I mean like
a bit of a loophole where it's a bit
hard to come out of it where I'm just
used to money being thrown at me I'm
scared to go back into a normal job
routine how how much in savings do you
have savings
um
do I really have to answer that do you
have more than like okay what do you
what do you roughly make a year yeah I'd
say maybe not on our Earth but all
together maybe I'd say about 50k 50k
yeah for you that's sex work yeah you
said you think you're worth 50k a year
no but I don't work a lot though with it
I do you know I don't overdo it because
when I was a bit younger I overworked
and that's when I was doing a really
black bad place I overdid it so I've
taken a bit of a step back I don't even
do my only only fans anymore
um I'm more do like Dominatrix and come
in and that just keeps me Steady for now
yeah well I'm just thinking if you want
to get out oh no of course of course
right so like like it might help to get
some savings so then yeah yeah I've got
savings I've got same don't get me wrong
I've got savings but also I've gotten a
lot of debt as well and I also had to go
for a court case so I'm spending money
on solicitors you know things happen in
life lies one big journey and I feel
like everyone's journey is different
some people have really good life and
some people don't have a good life so
what made you get into that well no sex
works yeah thing
um I used to work in a care home and I
was actually very like depressed very
low and I wasn't making a lot of money
and I had my ex-boyfriend at the time
that used to
he used to really make me feel low you
know and even like we'd go out for meals
and he'd say have you got the 10 pound
from the mill we used to always make me
split and I used to think to myself like
like I care for you I love you I treat
you try and treat you well and you never
gave me that back and then I worked in
the care home and I was sitting there
one day and I thought I can't do this
anymore my mind don't even want to help
like help
um
and then I'll sit in there and speaking
to one of the old guys I used to look
after in the care home and I told him my
whole plan about starting the only fans
you know and he sat there and he said to
me do it why are you not doing it you're
going to be old like me one day sitting
in a chair you're gonna like die
basically one day just do it and I
probably just wanted to subscribe yeah
you know what but he didn't make it till
that time because he passed away a few
months after but I started it and um I
was 19 to 19 you're working in a care
home you sorry it's harder it gets very
hot
question how many years did you run your
only fans
um
probably about a year and a half then I
stopped
yeah so I was working in the care home
and then I started it and I knew that if
I started the obf my ex would leave me
alone because he hated things like that
and I knew that he'd really leave me
alone because we were so toxic together
and then I was I was in work I checked
my phone I think I made maybe like 2K in
that day and to me that's a lot I
haven't come from a big family I haven't
come from a stable family at all I think
2K in a day as well and for me it was
because I was getting 400 pound a week
from their care home and I was working
12 hour shifts and five days a week so
to me that was amazing how did you see
you right now I'm 22 now okay so you've
been doing it for like three years yeah
and then um I said to my manager I'll
need to leave work like I don't really
want to be here and I told him my
situation was the only phone she said to
me just go so I went and I just never
looked back so why did you pick that
route instead of like I don't know
marrying rich
girl you were 19. thank you you were
with the guy for three years so you
couldn't have been I mean well you
probably weren't streeting that much so
if you're with a girl for three years
were you maybe you were okay yeah I was
a mess I was a mess I had no control
over my emotions I felt like I didn't
even know who I was right I feel like
when you're in a young relationship you
don't even know who you are as a person
at that point you grow to learn who you
are why ruin your own life you could
have got married ruin someone else's too
I don't want to get married I'm against
marriage I don't ever want to get
married thank you
I just think it's like a shame because
there's a way to utilize female Beauty
in a different way and still get the
outcomes that yeah you know what I mean
like now you're in a position where it's
gonna be tough to ever be with a guy
long term yeah but maybe I don't want to
be of a guy long term maybe I want to
live with free cats at my home with all
my cactuses what do you want your life
to look like at 65. I'll probably be
dead by then so I don't know I don't
think that far ahead because life
yeah it probably will but if it does it
does I don't really care yeah you do no
I don't I think you feel a bit under
yeah
then life hits you and
maybe it will hit me but it's not
hitting me up and I'm here I'm healthy
you know I'm living I've got good family
members like you still get it like I
don't think women like we realize how
much we like need attention from men
yeah like we need like we need I agree
with that and so like right now you're
still young you're still attractive
you're still gonna get attention from
men but like at 40 to 50 people women
become basically invisible yeah I know
that does scare me actually I thought
about that and so if you don't if you
don't get a husband before then like
what does life look like your parents
will pass away at some point your your
siblings will have their own families
like if you don't start thinking long
term like what does your life look like
and I don't say this to be mean no no no
it's because you're seriously you're in
the position you're in already you can't
do anything to like yeah yeah to change
it yeah but it's like you know if you
want to be in a position where you're
happier like wouldn't it make sense to
maybe start put that away
maybe but um I don't know I feel like
there's so much in my life I'm trying to
sort out first like my mental health and
my family issues and a lot of my
childhood trauma that I still have to
deal with daily so I'm trying to sort
that up first because I feel like I
can't think straight at the moment my
head is just like one big tornado so
it's so trauma like what do you mean you
need to go through like because I never
understand when people say childhood
trauma when I was younger I was essayed
and um it was my mum's boyfriend so
like that was quite intense you know
I'm not getting upset it's just a bit
you know
um yeah so how long have you been going
to therapy for it
um I was going when I was 16 for a year
and then I stopped before I didn't need
it anymore and then I've only been going
for about five months now well because
it's just like the
the sad thing about the therapy is it
just seems like they just kind of making
money off of their patients instead of
like trying to get you guys out and I
think a lot of times that's like women
doing it I know I know maybe you had the
bad experience with the guy but it might
make sense to try to find a different
yeah I think so you know that just
because like what what does your future
look like you have to figure out how to
move on yeah yeah definitely
yeah okay
and sometimes there are things that you
can't actually get over so looking at it
endlessly you makes you live in the
moment yeah I always feel like I'm I
wake up and I'm still living in the past
still like my head just keeps living in
the past you know and I've just found
that if I focus more on the future you
don't live as much in the past yeah I
know you know but like right now you're
not even thinking like long term yeah
also if you had a partner one that was
good for you not just any old partner if
you were focused on them yeah and
they're focused on you then you also
wouldn't have to I feel like that is why
I do hate my job because I don't
glamorize sex work at all I think don't
start it it does ruin your life it ruins
your mentality and it ruins how you view
men and how men should view you so yeah
if I could sit here and regret doing sex
work I probably would regret it only
because the stuff I put on the internet
as well because that's not me that's
just what I've done for money and you
shouldn't have to do them things for
money to you know you're losing your not
morals but it could have been private
yeah it could have been private and I
feel like where I was a bit younger and
I was getting too excited because of the
money I had no parents to guide me I
kind of lost the control and now I'm in
this situation
but um yeah I'm just thinking there's
like steps you could take to get out of
it because you know it's like you can
you're able to make savings put it away
yeah yeah learn like a skit because I'm
just thinking like you're you're a
pretty girl there's ways to monetize
your beauty in a different way yeah
start a YouTube channel yeah reaction
yeah right you could do you could do
um sales yeah I don't
would sales people 100 sex work sex
workers that's what's interesting to me
and this is actually something like I
said when I was dating a gal that turned
out to be a stripper and like a really
popular one apparently
um what really interested me in her
psychology she was probably the best
person I've ever met at just reading men
and just understand like I don't believe
that anybody really knows human nature
like sex workers do that's so they
really like these girls learn things
yeah she can look she can look at a guy
and I guarantee it I've met you like two
minutes ago we were going to show it's
like she can look at a guy and
immediately know how much money he has
would he cheat on his wife and how
quickly and like and she knows she would
you know you don't know right she's like
yeah of course because the gal I was
with she was like she was looking at
she's like I'm like oh that guy's my
friend he was married she's like oh he
would cheat on his wife and then I'm
like really and she would just know
she's like I know the look I know I know
the feel I know the energy like they
just understand that so yes it
definitely is good for sales but coming
I know that you did not like sales and
that's fine I loved sales I'll tell you
no no no I don't mind sales I hate
selling copiers yes we had a guy in our
company we had a guy in our company
that's like one of our top sales people
he used to sell copiers came to us he
likes his life now but there is
something um two sales that I think is
really really important tying into this
um how you feel and like all the
emotional stuff I mean obviously like
that's that's a battle you have to you
have to you have to fight that's a
battle you have to win it is what it is
everybody has some trauma not at the
same level you know we're different but
everybody comes everybody's family is
left up in some way or another like it's
just a fact we all are you know and one
thing I'm really glad about like when I
was 20 years old and I felt like I was a
victim of the world
and I think a lot of people you know at
a young age feel like they're victims
like no I'm not the best looking no I'm
not the smartest no I'm not this the
that I don't have a big brother to teach
me things before I was 20 the internet
wasn't like a huge thing which is kind
of crazy so we didn't have these
podcasts to learn about life which is
why I appreciate what Pearl does so much
because you know we get to learn about
life
I was really really lucky to to take a
sales position where people probably
cared about the money I was making them
more than they care about me but at
least the steps that I needed to take to
build myself included a significant
amount of discipline a significant
amount of accountability and being
honest with myself because I didn't get
paid if I didn't sell anything so so I
was had to be very brutally honest with
myself and extremely disciplined but
what really helped was getting around
another group of people around me that
were disciplined and growing and they
didn't resent My Success they celebrated
my success and I celebrated their
success and when I failed they didn't
crap on me they said hey you failed
let's work together to make you better
if you want to be better you know and so
one of the things actually we do in our
companies and I think tayden those guys
have the War Room people the worm was I
think that's brilliant I think just
giving men men a place to meet other
ambitious successful or striving men in
school yeah and that's we need that we
do the same thing in our company like we
bring guys in and we literally mold them
and work with them to make them more
accountable to grow and just some guys
resent it yes they leave and they resent
it because they don't like to be in an
environment where they feel like they're
not enough but other guys flourish in
that environment and as a man I'm
talking from a man's perspective you
don't have like a woman can cry and
still move into another man's life a
couple years later men don't have that
option like we need to be building all
the time and if you feel like you're a
dude and you're a little bit victimized
it's time to step up and and get around
people that will help you grow
I agree with that definitely works I'm
just thinking for you you've been doing
of for three years like that's three
years you can still get out you can
still haven't actually been doing it for
free I've been I did it for like really
I was on on it for like a year and a
half then the other two years I had it
but I never put any effort into it what
I'm saying is right now it's still you
can somehow you can semi get it off oh
no 100 kids I'd never want to be in a
sex work the rest of my life away the
way the way you're on track like that's
what you're on track to do if you don't
make life changes quick
I have been yeah what changes have you
been making I've made a limited company
and we'll start with a cleaning company
I just need to make my website at the
moment so I've got the cleaners for it
like not the cleans I've got the
um
what's it called why does my mind my
mind go I'm like you should get the of
girls
so my plan was to start a legit one
first year I've got um a friend he does
an Airbnb business so I thought I
couldn't use the cleaners for that to
start with and then make a Twitter page
and get the naughty mates in you know
what I mean the sugar does have the nice
houses
yeah
okay that's actually that's amazing and
remember one time I was on your show
while ago and and the story was like
um I told my wife we should get a
cleaner because we have four kids and
like a very large house with a lot of
toys and stuff and she's like okay final
try it and then the cleaner came and it
was this like young Ukrainian girl and
you cleaned the house spotlessly and she
was good looking and my wife's like I'm
never inviting the cleaner I will clean
so so women watching this not just the
men the women should be you know if
you're a guy and your wife's not
cleaning hire this lady in her company
your wife will be a cleaner yeah
um did you answer the question for how
many bodies is too ready for high value
uh no but uh we talked about this before
and uh I knew about the statistics about
the fair bonding so five was my number
before but you mentioned something about
two uh like the initial drop-off Point
yeah so I'm now adjusted
and I think that's the message that
sounds better to me honestly I think
that like women would be better if men
raise their standards especially like
the men that we want but it goes both
ways right that's true I think men need
to raise their standards for themselves
yeah like this this is crazy to me you
know like there's so many dudes that are
what is it like seven million men in the
USA are on a disability even though
they're not disabled that's an actual
statistic it's a crazy one yeah it's
like it's like you know men gaming the
social system in order to just smoke pot
and play video games or whatever like
like part of this I think the epidemic
is not necessarily in men having low
standards for women I think it's meant
having low standards for themselves and
I think there's this narrative in
society that like men should take on
these feminine characteristics you know
we have men competing women's sports
which is like and they see that as the
first no but the reason they see it as a
virtue it's like oh well a man should be
sensitive A man should be carrying a man
should be child I always try to make men
for women and then they go into women's
sports and now they have to celebrate it
otherwise they're Hypocrites right so so
I'm completely against the social
movement of like feminizing men I think
that men you know we used to be
conscripted into the army and we'd see
horrible horrible things in our early
20s and we'd come back and we were hard
men you know and I think Society needs a
little bit more of that and I and I
fully encourage men to take uh to take
more responsibility for being higher on
themselves raise your standards for
yourself a woman isn't interested in you
because of how you think of her a woman
is interested of you because of the man
you are sure do you think because I
always think like women would never be
single mothers and leave their husbands
if they knew no one would take them
if they knew and there wasn't a
government bailout well there's a
government bailout which messes up a lot
of things there's actually something I
was flying over here so I wasn't I was
in Budapest this morning I got on the
plane I flew here to London and I was
thinking about this on the flight and I
was sort of thinking about this in a
biblical sense you know and and this is
what I came out in my mind is who's
taming the devil let me explain that
real quick so women find themselves most
attracted to a man when they have to
tame the devil inside of them that's why
they go for these tyrones and chats
right it's like oh the guy's got this
streak of things and a woman thinks I
can save him I can be the one that bring
him out of hell I can be the one to
build him into the angel he can be so
the woman is trying to tame the devil
and that keeps the relationship together
but when it works the other way when a
man is trying to tame the devil and a
woman I can get I can rescue her life I
can give her the life because she
doesn't she's a singer she's a single
mom I can help her now right and that's
where everything breaks down so like as
a man you have to make yourself
dangerous
and then it works
in a powerful man's situation when
you've got money you've got status and
all those things yes but when you're
talking about younger girls with like
the Chads and the guys those guys are
the ones that younger girls are trying
to tame and think oh he'll change for me
he'll love me you can't keep those
relationships together the woman can
never keep that relationship together
because that guy doesn't have to choose
you and he isn't going to choose you
well my wife hang on a second like I was
when my wife married me I was making
well over a million dollars a year and I
was like I met her at 26. uh and and she
and she got me to commit and and
honestly very happily but are you a chad
what are you yes I think so if you don't
think so that's fine you don't have to
think so I was let's see 26 years old
six foot four playing ice hockey four
times a week making 1.6 million dollars
a year at 26 that was me okay and so you
you don't have to think I was a chat but
when you're in like was I was I getting
checks yeah lots okay but I'm not I'm
not saying that like I can't relate with
money gets gets gold back to gym forget
about the minimum money they didn't even
know they didn't know I had it normal
normal situations normal life normal
going out to the club not I have never
met a million you know Millionaires and
things like that so I'm not talking
about that but generally those guys
you've like killed my point because
the point the point was to kill your
point because because here's the thing
85 listen 85 of millionaires are married
85 percent of billionaires are married
the marriage statistics for men actually
go up the wealthier they are and the
divorce rates go down the wealthier
manners so what should a man's goal be
if he truly wants to build a happy
successful life is to get
more money now well because you'll say
like definitely they won't settle down
but it's more like like the women
probably just aren't good enough yeah no
I I possibly for those yeah for those
men you know I've watched one once and
it's men date down women date up or
sleep up and I agree with that 100
um so that that's probably the case as
well that he's sleeping with you but he
won't consider you as a woman and there
were lots of women like that in my life
and that's fine they just then meet the
criteria that I wanted for a wife yeah
but so you obviously you talk a lot from
the man's perspective but we could also
teach women not to even look at those
guys because they're not like if you're
not if you're not that's something I
have two daughters I'll tell you right
now 100 look at those guys 100 [__] not
the million I'm talking about the ones
that aren't millionaires Ambitions who
just have she's talking about are you
talking about the broke yes the average
guy the uh yes she's talking about
heartbrokes
with swag
because they can't even
they don't even have drip where I come
from you like can't even afford their
own but they can afford a pair of blue
that's the danger that's the I think
dating is more difficult for women than
it is for men and the reason I believe
it's more difficult for women is because
you're putting yourself in a position
where like if you commit to the wrong
guy or give yourself the wrong guy hey
it will lower your value for the next
high value guy and B you can lose your
market value as that time passes right
yep so women women have to be you can be
attracted to those guys and everything
but it's like you have to draw the line
of where do you think your chances are
for a potential relationship with this
man I also know a couple of girls used
to work in our company like one example
she was 22 23 one of the most beautiful
girls I've ever seen she was working on
our company she was an amazing
salesperson right met a guy now she
lives on a yacht Monaco and that guy
committed to her and they're happy and
they've been together for for a pretty
long time and it's like she was not only
attractive and garnering attention she
was also a great judge of character and
potential and that's the hard part it's
like it's easy for a guy to judge looks
but it's real hard for a woman to judge
a man's character and potential but
those men do exist 85 percent of
millionaires are married statistically
speaking men who are married once and
retired married uh have I think four
times more money than men who get
divorced and twice more than men who get
divorced and remarried but those that
got divorced and remarried still have
twice the amount of wealth so successful
Men actually marry and by the way uh if
you want to find a successful manner
because the girl's like oh they're never
married that's not true there's
significant Opera they're significant
business
um business how do I put this there's
positive business outcomes for men who
are married because men want to do
business with other men who are doing
good things for the community who are
trustworthy and reliable so a lot of
times when you're doing business you ask
the guy about his wife and his kids and
his family and you don't trust the guys
so much that are 42 and single trying to
get you to invest a million bucks you
trust the guy that's 42 who's got a wife
and three four kids and they've been
married for 15 years that's the guy you
trust so there's a lot of
Market pressure on the successful guys
to do that you just have to be the right
girl
I've worked in this sex industry for a
long time and most of the men that come
to me are rich married men
yeah exactly they're they're rich and
they're married I don't get broke men
come it's the rich and the married men
that are happy in their relationships
but you're not because you're finding
pleasure somewhere else wait so I'm I'm
curious like what what do you do is the
dominatrix
okay so how do you know how much money
they make
because they tell me I've been to their
houses before Oh so yeah and I see all
their girlfriends and their wives
pictures
so you'll go to their actual hat I'm
like I'm sorry I don't dominatrix that
like when you would you know when you're
a horrible now for them
Wall Street is that like that stuff
um I'd say a bit more extreme like
making money from the toilets
um oh my goodness yeah men pay for this
rich men people in the politics okay
people will do politics and stuff you'll
find them all there they want you to hit
them and make them eat from the toilet
can I ask you a question and they go
home to their wife and kiss them can I
ask you are these two two questions I'm
actually really interested so number one
are these guys that you would find
conventionally charismatic and
attractive or like they would get other
chicks anyways or they would not I've
had very good looking men and very ugly
men like what second question the very
good looking man is there a risk because
you you're one thing that you offer like
my friend says this that a sex worker
offers it's not it's not this sex that
they offer it's the Privacy it's the
Kent it's like the fact that there's not
going to be leaving yeah yeah are these
good looking guys and get other checks
is for them is it because it's just a
safer way to do it
yeah maybe yeah yeah because there may
be political probably won't go out and
speak to them and they can confide in me
because they know I don't know them they
don't know me and they could block my
number and never talk to me again and
I'd never be able to contact them anyway
so they're paying for privacy you have
to sign ndas or anything
um
sometimes I mean I've done it's worse
and only because one of the people that
came to me actually knew him I didn't
want him to you know leak uh how many
rich men have you so you've done this
about three three four years how many
Richmond clients have you had
I only see high-class men so all of them
wow yeah probably not all of them but
very very high majority of them are
reckon it out of all of them I've
probably seen 10 low-class men
is that because of like is that because
of you sorry is that kind of because of
your Market specifically like or is that
typical among do you have friends that
do the same thing
um I have quite a few friends there in
like the industry but my main friends
work their minds if I have some stuffs
um but I met like out of your other
friends that do sex work are their
clients mostly Rich too yeah wow yeah
I'd say so yeah surprising to me it's
not surprising at all it makes perfect
sense now by the way just just to be
clear just because all your clients are
rich men does not mean that all rich men
do the kind of thing right it's like
statistically it's about 20 uh 20 of men
that cheated the higher income bracket
and statistically it's about 20 of women
of the lower income bracket but as a
man's income goes up his propensity to
cheat grows from like 13 to about 20 and
sort of levels at about 200 000 and then
for a woman her propensity to cheat
actually drops from 20 down to about 13
as a man's income goes about 200 000.
I've looked at some of the interesting
charts about that
um so I just want to be like yes that
obviously exists but it's not already
yes but I think but it makes sense that
it would be Richmond because they just I
think it's a financial thing yeah like
for a lot of guys to drop 500 bucks
could be a lot of money but if it
doesn't mean anything to you it's like
what whatever yeah yeah what is it
called what do you cost
um it depends so in half an hour an hour
uh overnight is that cleaning sorry
we're talking about yeah
because the domination sexual they're
not allowed to touch you you're
basically a goddess in their eyes you
know it's not like a schooling service
it's not like that so overnight I charge
1.5 k for an hour 300 pounds with 100
pound deposit and that's not even
including the extras because they want
me to do really dirty things I put their
head in the toilet or maybe poo on them
I'm not ashamed of it I've done it I
have done it no one's ever done it to me
but I have done it to them and I'll
admit that
um yeah was he a good looking guy yeah
he actually that he actually was he
actually was
it you don't want to meet him in the
street be like I think he's nice it
feels more wrong when they're good
looking for some reason because it feels
like they shouldn't even be there yeah
you know I think and I say to them why
are you here they say because it's just
easier and I like my fetishes and you
know you said about the fat woman that
so many men that have a fetish of fat
women and but they won't admit to the
public because it's shameful but they
love it that's what I was like they love
but they're not marrying them
when I said earlier just because the guy
wants to crap on you and that's like
whatever you crap on them and that's
like you don't consider I was being like
nice yeah I was being like that was a
hyperbole I was really exaggerating
do they do do guys ever pay to like crap
on the girls they do but I'd never do
that I'm I'm the one that's in the power
world no man could ever do that to me
not even if he was Chris Brown or
whatever you know one see this is what I
find I find this perplexing because it's
you know so a rich guy will marry the
high value woman but he still wants what
he wants yeah so this is this is you
might like steak every day but every now
and then you got to get a McDonald's you
know what I mean
every day every now and then McDonald's
is nice I feel like that's why I get a
bit confused because where I get the
really high class men come to me
sometimes it confuses me because I'm
like you shouldn't be here so they don't
want that so in my eyes they don't want
the high value the High Valley woman is
for their own ego and this no it's a
high value
for the children not for the show for
the children for the children and
obviously that's good if you if you're
with a really high class person it makes
yourself look better as well because
whoever you're with reflects on who you
are as a person as well I just I just
think it's like what they want long term
like I think men will always crave
variety which yeah definitely is whales
I guess yeah yeah I don't know yeah yeah
but a fetish is always a good thing like
I don't know there's a reason why they
hires and fetishes
not every fetish needs to be played out
exactly yeah this is even a fetish and
um guys will pay you to pop balloons
with your bum cheeks and it's like what
why like how does that turn
all these men that do come to me it does
root down to some sort of childhood
issue or trauma it definitely does
because even like the whole dominatrix
thing where they like being her abused
and called horrible names
they've they've got issues they've got a
lot of issues and they're issues that
they need to obviously maybe
it's like
mommy issues maybe yeah like I've had
men cry to me before and sit in my lap
what do they know you about just their
life they've got money and they hate
their life and they're always on drugs
like what do they say what are their
problems just they're not helping them
in their marriage they're always working
they're always stressed they're always
on
you know do you know why do you know why
I'm not happy in their marriage I go to
their complaints I mean I don't really
go to not just kind of just let them cry
on me wow but yeah no because after that
I leave my own therapy when I deal with
men like that
um but yeah
yeah that's what I mean so it's very
mentally draining for me to do this job
and I know I shouldn't be in it because
it's like I'm taking on everyone else's
trauma and I need to deal with man first
so yeah just a caveat like again because
all these guys come to doesn't mean that
all guys that are like that do go to
that kind of a service the reality is
that wealthier people do do report a
significantly higher uh statistical uh
mean of being satisfied with their life
and they report a significantly higher
happiness uh sort of index to their
marriage which is again why 85 percent
of millionaires are married so what
you're reporting is not actually the
norm that is The Fringe of that it just
is I just want guys to understand it
because there's some guys here listening
like oh see that's why I don't be
successful because I'm just going to be
sad no statistically you'll be way
happier you'll be way happier just trust
me guys build yourself oh no definitely
definitely yeah I feel like you just get
the odd um rich men who obviously aren't
doing it the right way they're abusing
themselves with drugs and things like
that some everyone loves their life you
know I'd rather cry enough yeah yeah
yeah yeah
um okay for the guys have you ever
stopped dating a girl because of her
past
what happened what'd you find out
um
so I found out uh I was 18 found out
that the girl
yeah is that better for you tell it
yeah okay cool
um 18 I found out the girl had slept
with like multiple men and this was
through a conversation that I had heard
from one of my friends saying oh boss
that girl like I know she's been with
like this guy and that guy and as soon
as I heard that and said to the girl why
did he tell me a strange number you told
me this number and now I'm finding out
it's more than likely this and she broke
down and said oh I didn't want to talk
to you about all these girls all these
men sorry blah blah blah for me that was
the end of it why do women say body
count doesn't matter if they don't want
to tell you what it is exactly it does
matter as far as I'm concerned it does
matter a woman wouldn't
tell you I've slept with 8 000 men and I
still want to be with you she won't say
that at all a woman will keep it at a
certain level like I understand where
you're saying about it doesn't matter it
shouldn't matter Etc but when push comes
to shove if you get the ideal man in
front of you you're not gonna tell him I
have slept with
800 men you're not going to do that
there is no woman on this Earth that's
actually going to do that you're going
to downplay it or you're going to
Gaslight like you were saying before and
you're gonna say actually do you know
why are you asking me these questions
it's the modern day era you should ask
me this that's what I think is going to
happen there's actually something we say
that's kind of uh funny I'm like there
is a kind of girl that will lie about
her number and lie up and that's a whale
me personally I think like
because we have
broke it off one time with that girl but
it was mainly it wasn't even the body
count like I knew it was high ish but
it's like
doing something with someone I know I
think who was it
um
it wasn't like a it was a friend but
it's not like one of the brothers but
it's like a friend like I know him but
it's more like you've done stuff for him
and
I don't think I can view here after that
I know what he's like as a person you
know you're eating the same hole oh
[__] like I know him from being a player
you know I mean but it's like you've
been with him I mean like for me my like
standards I think that's where like
standards comes in like you've been with
that guy and now I'm with you like come
on like what's going on you know what I
mean but I think that was one of them
was he kind of a loser like was it
because he was more High status than you
or less High status I think it was
because he was less
so if you thought he was a quality guy
would have been different
um
I wouldn't think it would have been
different but just because I know him I
think that makes a big difference if I
didn't know the person then probably
like I would have been like okay fair
enough that can slide I don't know but
because you knew it was difficult
annoyed personally he's like yeah that
guy really you know what I mean uh what
about you have you ever stopped speaking
to a woman because of something she did
before uh no that never happened to me I
only had one girl which was like the
secondary so it wasn't a proper
relationship that's about it okay yeah
um did you have any other girls that
happened to you or the one yeah I just
learned to recognize it's like you just
learned to recognize the sign quicker
but you know as a man when I was single
it doesn't mean that I disqualified her
from sex it just means
um that's what it was and that's all it
was what what signs for guys that are
watching this like what signs should
they look out for man that's a I mean
I'm gonna your tattoos would be a pretty
big sign
um just any like I'll tell you why
tattoos are big so you might say well
that's not nice because I have tattoos
I'll tell you why it's a big sign
because if you had a good relationship
with your dad he wouldn't let you
tattoos when you were 18. no that's what
it means that's what that's why I don't
have tattoos right so yeah it's like
that's literally it's like it just tells
me you don't have a good relationship
with your dad which it doesn't mean for
everybody but it raises those numbers
there's there's obviously
um the thing about social intelligence
it's very hard to describe it because
it's so nuanced like and you really have
to sort of
um conflate a big number of variables
all into one and that's what comprises
like the social intelligence thing so
it's hard to say like oh because of this
and this and this and that
um but there's definitely signs and when
you know you know but it's like the dead
thing or like what if she didn't have a
dad like my Apple it goes to the shop
and don't come back you know I mean like
what if she didn't have a dad like how
would you look but that also tells me of
course look I'm not saying it's her
fault it's still her responsibility
there I understand it's not her fault
but it is her responsibility and it may
be like while I was young whatever okay
fine I'm not responsible for that thank
you I'm not I think you are now right
you are now people for your life you are
responsible for your life
I know you're not responsible for that
but even when I hear you talk like you
you sort of blame it on everyone else
but you but you kind of you kind of
blame like your situation and like this
is like like instead of It's My Life
Choices
whoever blamed
um it was just earlier when you were
saying it's because of like this or
because of that like you're not it adds
to it my my child and stuff is it's kind
of molded me into a bit of a mess and
I'll admit that I think she means like
if you if you get like a young guy who
doesn't have his dad there some of those
guys end up alcoholics in prison and
some of them end up like amazing deaths
do you know what I mean so like you can
come from the same background and have
two different completely different and
that's choices definitely is five
choices
I came from a life which was if I put
like I said I've put on camera before
and what the reaction from people I came
from a life that was an absolute mess
and I chose not to go down a certain
path like I didn't want to be like the
man that brought me into this world yeah
and I didn't want to be
and let my mom down even though my mum I
haven't seen her for 13 years because
she's schizophrenic so I decide I'm not
going to prison so I have no remorse for
people when they say oh well this
happened so therefore I've become this
I've Got No Remorse for that because you
don't have to one of the bad one of the
best women I know came from a single
parent home and she was abused as a kid
and she's like genuinely one of the best
women I know because she like went to
the church and she sought after like
women she could look up to and she ended
up getting married and having a family
but it's like you can go down you can be
from the same situation and have a
completely different life outcomes and
that's what he's saying he's saying it's
your responsibility what you do with
your life your responsibility but not
everyone's strong like sure not everyone
has that mindset some people actually
weak and I'll admit I've had times in my
life where I felt so weak I didn't want
to be anymore but why would I want to be
with a girl that's weak that's good
don't think of me no I'm not but I'm
saying that's what that's his point yeah
yeah okay cool what are you speaking to
man like yeah you better watch this show
yeah these are the signs and it's not
even for women like honestly I think
it's better to date people from two
parent homes yeah no definitely
definitely definitely because it's
easier when you've had a model like
something yeah yeah
there is a way so I I've spent
significant amount of my time in my
youth thinking about this because I
realized I was a really bad judge of
character of women because when I was
like young like coming out of high
school going to college and stuff I
remember the girls I was falling for and
trying to be in relationships with they
just were horrible people and I think I
thank the good Lord above every day that
I didn't get what I wanted when I wanted
it at 20 because if I had gotten what I
wanted I would have signed up for a life
of massive regret you see a lot of those
guys they get married young and then
they just get wiped out right and
sometimes you know I'll go on on the
show and then guys will comment like
that guy is going to get what's coming
to them blah blah blah it's like no and
I'll tell you why not here's here's if
you're a guy here's how you can tell
what a girl is like okay make it your
mission to go out in your early 20s and
and just sleep with as many girls as you
can and you might say that's horrible
advice no that's great advice because
what you're going to learn first of all
you're going to learn about the nature
of women
and I'm not saying do that for your
whole life like eventually you will grow
up eventually you will want to pursue a
higher purpose but in order to pursue
that higher purpose valiantly you have
to understand the game you're playing
and you don't understand the game you're
playing if you've been with one or two
girls
and you might say that's bad advice
that's exactly the advice I'll give my
sons and I'll give my daughters the
opposite advice if you want to know
about the seriousness of men don't put
out with them absolutely then you'll
absolutely learn what men are really
after but if you want to learn women or
after go out as a man remember it's not
your job to protect the sexual
Marketplace as a man it's the woman's
job to protect that she's the guardian
to that you're the guardian's
relationships you want to get socially
intelligent do it lots of times
I know what he's saying but obviously
back when say my nan and Granddad got
married my grandma picked a lady and
they were like teenagers got married but
women back in those days marriages
worked without men having to go and do
that so it is the only way but I do
understand the difference is women today
aren't the women no no no no absolutely
the women are like that's what I
realized I used to hear that like I'd
hear Myron say sleep with 50 women
before you settle down I'm like why
would you do that yeah I realized is
like men can be manipulated by a woman
that's more experienced than him like
you know imagine you you date a virgin
right you you you would eat him up she's
smart you know you could get him to do
exactly what you wanted when you want
yeah yeah I can understand that yeah
yeah it's like like it's not good for us
to be in relationships with men that
have less experience no I do agree the
guy has got to be more experienced more
powerful more anything the woman has got
to feel lower and it
do you guys think we're having a crisis
of female evil in the world because one
in three women and female like
femininity because one in three women
have had abortions one in four women
have an STD
oh I think I wouldn't say evil because
it sounds like women are deliberately
but I think women have got no idea what
they're looking for no they've got too
much permission too much Freedom too
yeah that's what about the same time
there's too much Freedom too much
encouragement to you know get I think I
think it's evil
do you think the women are yes or I
think the women influence has no I think
that's like a way I think as women like
we're always trying to take
accountability off of us
influenced and guided Society but I
think I think it's female I think one
part of women that's like okay I think
there's male evil and female evil and
I'm gonna butcher this a little bit okay
but I think I think male evil is like
grape right that's an example of
aggressiveness but I think women can be
very selfish yeah definitely and I think
like men will do more for like a
community and like they'll build a
society that's not like they gave us the
right to vote in a society that they
built because they thought it was the
right thing to do now you know some
people don't think that they should but
that's a different conversation but but
like women like we can be very it's like
they call it solid
I can't say the word but basically
really selfish right and I think like
women when we kill our children that's
like a part of female evil because we're
thinking of us before our kids yeah 100
because some people can be like one
minute pregnant and they're just
absolutely thrilled at the idea of this
little tiny thing right inside them and
somebody else sees that as like a pain
oh my God my body I need to kill it like
that needs to die you know for yourself
so it's two different perspective but
then
women are supposed to be that way
naturally you know mothers and it's
maternal
nurturing you're supposed to so I don't
know what what's happened no it's not I
mean it's not women evil it's the it's
yeah it's not that pearlite this is
where I think you and I a little bit
disagree I don't think it's a pandemic
of women being evil uh women's Nature
has been known to to everybody for a
long time look at how religions have
naturally developed in religions every
single religion has one basic purpose to
control a woman's sexuality that's true
in every religion in every major so
interesting every single religion
controls a woman's sexuality so you have
to wonder why because a lot of these
religions some develop from each other
but some develop totally independently
and yet they all have the same
converging factors that they're
controlling women's sexuality because
because there is a realization that
women are naturally hypergamous and that
creates a great imbalance when women are
hypergamous right because then all the
women go for the same guy we know this
right and so the problem is when all the
women go for the same guy you have an
imbalance in society and the way that
religion tries to tame that as they say
we're going to equalize the sexual
marketplace right but this was also at a
time where women had less freedom and
men were more masculine the real issue
is not that women are evil the real
issue is that men aren't masked still
enough because women will submit and I
like to use the word surrender women
will surrender to a strong focused
masculine man they desire it they crave
it and some people watching this like
you can't say that your suitable company
that's offensive and yet Every Woman
hearing that is like dear Lord I so want
to submit myself to a masculine focused
right strong man that's exactly what
they want where are these where are you
guys right that's what we teach it's
like that's what we talk about but I
think it shows like what happens when
women get power in a society but we
create a system that oppresses men and I
think that's why we see the lack of
masculine men is because we're in a
system there's not enough men that are
fighting it back and saying you're wrong
you're like like not to you specifically
but saying to like when women are like
here's how many to feel there's too many
whippy-ass guys that are trying to get
laid they're like you're right ladies
too you just want to get light but it
starts in like freaking like what are
they supposed to do it starts in like
Pre-K for them with their schools I move
countries for this I moved out of Canada
I'm I left Canada as our first as we
were pregnant with our first child I
left Canada with with my wife we went to
Estonia which still has some of those
more traditional values and that woke
crap is not there because I totally not
it is not at all because it's a no the
reason you don't find that like in
Romania Hungary Bulgaria in the a lot of
the Baltic and the Balkan states that
are ex-soviet we've been through this
our parents left those countries because
ideology overtook reality and everybody
just became poor and stupid my parents
didn't want that now it's happening in
the west and so I left I said I'm not
having my kids go through this
ideological brainwashing I don't want it
for my kids and if I told my wife if it
starts coming to the schools here we're
going to the Middle East man we're going
to Dubai where that shit's not going to
happen and I'm really intentional about
what my kids are learning but I'm just
I'm just more like trying to explain
like why I think it happened and I and I
think genuinely like men are feminized
from such a young age like oh my gosh I
hear guys talk about how like teachers
or red flags on dating apps because
they're such feminists and then I'm in
school for psychology it's like a guy
goes to a therapist and now he has a
feminist therapist he goes to a lawyer
he has a it's like everybody let's just
defend everybody while we're here a lot
of women are like I will only date a man
in therapy it's like if you're a man if
you're a man if you're a man in therapy
you need to go get your face punched
you need to straight up just go
just good but I see it and I know people
in the in the combat life and other
things that are really successful and
I've learned a lot of I know several I
think therapy makes you worse for the
most part I think okay if you got real
people PTSD
go to therapy you know what I mean maybe
right not even all of you but like for
like they used to go to therapy for like
War literally George said yes yes now
it's like I remember there was this
interview on Joe Rogan right and it was
that that girl that escaped like North
Korea Kim Jong-un yeah yeah and she it
was this crazy story like she she
basically got graped in order to escape
she had to like escape slavery all this
like crazy stuff and she had a horrible
horrible life and she comes back and
she's so confused because she's like
what is therapy I just moved on yeah and
then and then she like her roommates are
going to therapy over her cry they're
crying like over their ex-boyfriends and
she's like I've literally escaped death
like nobody escapes North Korea there's
only two types of therapy and I tell
this to the boys in our group it's like
we're we're in sales we're cold calling
on the phone you need some phone therapy
I need some gym therapy that's your
therapy
pick up the phone start making money go
to the gym start making muscle that's
there I think what they're doing is
doing is sourcing families like you're
supposed to go to your mother your
brothers your sisters and they can give
you a completely different perspective
perpetuation than a therapist is going
to because okay if my sister comes to me
and says this person reacted like this
this is the problem I know my sister so
I know how my sister talks more than the
therapist so the therapist might say oh
well you poor baby everyone hates you
they're gaslighting you they use these
like crazy words for problems like
gaslighting trauma all this [__] and
when I would be like well you were
probably being a [__] to her you know
what I mean because I I know myself or
maybe she would say to me you know you
were doing this because who knows you
better than their family but the problem
is they're they're saying that the dad's
not important so they're kicking the dad
out of the home with the policies that
they push now we have our single parent
homes and the birth rate is going down
where we only have 1.2 kids how are you
going to talk to siblings if you have
none
and so it's like they're Outsourcing the
things to straight like why would a
stranger give you better advice than
someone that loves you and wants the
best for you nice sure it's true but all
of us have family good family members
you know sometimes it's loud words you
go through yeah and that's women's fault
yeah because because
I know it yeah it is because women we
have all the sexual power right now so
if if um not not the kid's fault but
like the parents usually it's the woman
because the woman usually leaves when
we're in relationships we usually
divorce if we get married or we pick the
guys that don't make good husbands like
we're in control sex tends to come
before relationships in 2023 so women
are 100 in control of sex so really I
think that women have ruined Society in
a way by by breaking up families
in my family it's the men that have done
it all right not not one woman in my
family no yeah not not one woman that I
know in my family that I'm close with is
married and their husbands have cheated
left they've all chosen to surrender to
that man whose fault is that it doesn't
sound like they're very good at choosing
no they're not they're not I'm curious
what happened with your would you mind
what happened with your parents my
parents um my dad he was used to great
my mom used to beat her up used to like
abuse her were you when he left
I don't know if it was I was probably
about
seven seven okay do you remember yeah I
remember him
I remember everything because a lot of
times like women
um and I'm I'm just saying this because
I'm I'm like doing a documentary on
divorce yeah um a lot of times they
don't tell the guy's side of the story
and so I I would this this smart doctor
is a criminal he's a big criminal yeah
yeah like like okay everyone knows he's
not a very good person so so why why did
your mom pick him she was 15 and she had
a baby and he used to put guns to her
head and stuff and he used to make her
just do things he was scared he used to
threaten to kill my nan kill the family
don't she hates the baby was it you or a
different baby just me that's the only
one I would teared to pick him like
before that yeah she did she was young
she was a kid still I was 15. yeah where
was her dad that was my next he turned
gay
he what he was gay
so he was with my nan and then crazy
yeah yeah yeah crazy and this is what
I'm trying to get over in my life so
um my nan was with my Grandad for [__]
in 18 years and then
found out he was gay he left the family
moved to a different country and then
obviously my man's parents died around
that time so my mom lost
um grandparents and then she had me she
went she went to UNI mom's a qualified
heart nurse now so she to me she did
well for everything that we did go
through as a family
um but yeah and do you think your life
would be different if you had two
parents in your life definitely yeah 100
because I don't have that guidance this
is where it's so important on women to
choose correctly because if you don't
choose correctly it affects everyone
else yes it's not just like when we pick
someone it's really not about us it's
about our kids because if you have kids
with the wrong guy like you now like you
know you're in a situation where you you
know you've done sex work and it's going
to be harder for you and like yeah
definitely and the trauma like continues
yeah it's like one big circle yeah yeah
you know what's crazy to me because I
grew up in Jamaica right and I grew up
in my Nano and I live I learned both
from another you know I learned
the man side of things and I let the
female side of things she learned me how
to work hard how to do things and it's
like
other granddad but I didn't learn that
from him I just learned all that from my
Nano and my mom and dad they can't
really teach me much because I've
learned so much from Orlando over the
past years but what my dad tell me I'm
like I already know that because my nana
actually told me I've seen my mother do
it you know what I mean like this time
where it's like we're getting hurricanes
storms stuff like that and then I will
be outside how did you learn how to like
tie a tie and like do like fix a car do
you know how to do that stuff yeah I do
and your nana taught you yeah there's
none that taught me all of it and it's
literally like looking at women back
then and looking at a woman now it's
like different story it's different
story it's like and it's like I think
it's social media and all the technology
because it's like the more you the more
you know
it's like it's the worst fee the less
you know is the better I think also
sorry did you say you were from Jamaica
yeah so do you think the gender roles
are more clear and to make it do you
think people stick to that more so your
nan would have thought you're a boy you
learn this or because I obviously hear
that's not really as
um popular yeah I think it's a bit
different here it's like yeah I think
it's a good thing that you were taught
all those things it's it's like hey it's
like hey you're a female no you're a
female hey your male no you're male but
it's like when push comes to shoving you
have to do things yeah you're not a male
or a female you just need to get that
done you know what I mean and that's
what my nana taught me as a person sorry
I didn't mean that your nun wasn't being
a woman I meant that she knew you were a
boy and you had to learn these things if
whether there was a man there to teach
it or not is what sorry what I was
getting yeah I think I get what you're
saying but I think as a man it's
important to learn about both sides you
know it's not just oh you're a man just
be a man and not learn how a female
thinks or operate you know what I mean I
think it's important as a man that you
should know how to be a tattoo if I'm
inside but you can still be masculine
you know what I mean like can I say
something yeah so I grew up with a mom
and dad so they were like married for 25
years and then my parents divorced in
like 2017.
and my whole life because my dad like he
had cancer so he was on pension money so
he was doing like what a woman should do
at home and then my mom was doing like
what a man should do so like
my mom was like doing her
part-time job as a care worker and then
my dad was at home like cleaning cooking
like doing what
a woman should do and then
when I was younger I thought like that
was normal but now I realize like I'm 23
now
it should it shouldn't have never been
that way
they did what was necessary didn't they
to yeah yeah it was needed do you think
that affected their relationship yeah
because like now my mom is married with
a younger guy
um
like that guy does everything for her
that I'm like my dad didn't do
because like my dad like like my mom
told my dad like oh yeah get a job you
know like bring some money in and then
my dad was just like
he he thought he was doing enough like
you know taking the kids to school
cleaning cooking and for my mom I don't
think that was enough for her so she
left him it's very hard to find that
attractive I think isn't it for a woman
even if it feels harsh that you just
can't you can't control that you can't
lie to yourself about it
why why do you think women tell men that
they want a guy that's in touch with
their emotions when they leave guys that
are I think they think it's true when
they say it when I see it
because because we're living in a
society no because we live in a society
on social media and that kind of that
kind of a statement on social media gets
you you go girl hard hard matter of
crack trash we should be in touch
whatever because we're we're respecting
attention more than we respect outcome
like it goes like a cuddle so you think
that's what you I mean when you're
sitting lonely at home you think you're
missing a cuddle yeah so that's what
you've yeah not when you're ovulating so
that's the problem right it's like
that's an emotional response you know
it's interesting like I thought about
this well it is it is because different
types of different types of the site
different times in the site you're going
to want different things you're gonna
you know put that out to the world some
guy's gonna read that all all I have to
do is tell a girl that I like to cuddle
and I'll have lots of girls and that's a
bad thing the girl is wrong when she
thinks of course she is wrong but that's
what you think in the moment that you're
on your own swipe you know for somebody
I made a decision so my mom had earned
my dad and then they got divorced after
like 22 years which is not surprising
because my mom started to order my dad
and she was like oh yeah that's kind of
cool I made a decision way before I ever
got married that my wife was not gonna
work like I'm like I'm gonna retire my
wife I'll talk and I'll tell you the
base of my but the basis of that
decision for me was really interesting
right it's it's rooted in the fact that
if my wife works it's because she has to
work obviously in order to help support
the family and then let's say my wife
wants to make more money and she has a
traditional job then she has to ask for
a raise and who's she gonna ask for a
raise
her boss and it's statistically kind of
likely you know men tend to work a lot
more hours because they're not you know
faced with the burden of childbearing
it's kind of likely she's gonna have to
go to another man to ask for an increase
in her lifestyle I find that really
offensive to my marriage if my wife has
to approach another man and he's in
control of our lifestyle wow that's like
to me that's a pimp and that's that was
my the base of my decision like my wife
will never ask another man for an
increase in lifestyle and you do the
same for your daughters right 100 100
that's interesting
um I didn't realize how inverse the
relationship like basically when women
started working that's when we stopped
having children like I I didn't realize
how like because I always thought it was
with birth control and it partially is
but when women
um basically started going to college
and working in the 20s that's like when
the birth rate started to drop
it was at like four or five a hundred
years ago now it's at like 1.5 imagine
putting that into just a dating because
a lot of people watching the show
probably a little bit younger I'm 40 and
they're probably like just in the dating
State imagine like you're a guy dating a
girl and she wants to go on a date and
she goes to another man to ask for his
money so that you can go on a date with
her it's like who's paying for that date
that's scary
not far ahead oh um I'm gonna Read Super
chat for a second
okay guys make sure you like the video
and let's get to a thousand likes okay
there's over a thousand of you in here
we have 780 likes 780 I think unless I
didn't refresh it and it's more
sometimes I do
that's a lot it's like it's like happy a
like is free this is just rude this is
just rude
um it's like okay
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna read the super
chats
but I'm gonna be upset if after we are
still we are not at a thousand likes
this is this is crazy guys okay Joe W
don't forget about Poland Dimitri we
went through uh commie ideology two huge
respect to my Slavic brother I'm proud
of you man some advice for short Kings
how do we overcome that disadvantage
we're gonna do that after I read the
super chats I'll ask him okay Dion uh C
Pearl do a show with Auntie and Dimitri
on the sofa the two of them would put so
many people on the right track in life
Dimitri you rock I think that's a great
idea interracial relationships Auntie's
um she's in the she's out of town for a
bit but she'll be back interracial
relationships I'm a 41 year old
currently with a 21 year old who pursued
me for weeks I'd accepted that I wasn't
going to be able to perform sexually at
the best until I gave into her advances
in a week we had we had it 15 times wow
that is a lot of times you are a happy
man okay guys now know I bet he's not
stepping out you know what I mean
guys no wonder she drinks pickle juice
she's disgusting sorry
everything is Haram in Islam is is bad
for you and the closer you are to the
teachings of Islam the more based and
happy you are research Islam yourselves
or talk to two Scholars because the
media lies you know I recently had
someone try to convert me on the streets
yeah and sometimes I'm like you don't
know who you're coming up to but I had a
very interesting conversation they gave
me a Quran
um Dion C Dimitri I'm so glad you're
back on the show still The Godfather of
this of the show you need to get a
YouTube channel set up Willie I'm paying
Jolene something uh I'm sorry guys I'm
not good at pronouncing names it's just
like my My Kryptonite in life what if
government gave free cars for 25-year
marriage with kids and free house for
50-year marriages with kids shout out to
my fellow single dads
that would be a better incentive than
the one we have now which pays you to
leave but
um I I do this fly chat this girl is not
attractive
um Gus
um the men in the front row are an
example that the symptom is real as a
simp who wants women with experience
they aren't good leaders you can attract
the women they want thanks for putting
the Simpson their place
um Carlos uh for pickles please watch
the jar because classy ladies with neck
tattoos will be trying to drink it when
you're not looking let me Let me refresh
it one more I'm not glossy I'll put it
out there I'm not I never will be I'm
not a classy woman
um okay so the the short comment well
first of all two things number one
pickle juice has a name it's brine
b-r-i-n-e so that's use that for your
next World
um and I think calling you pickle isn't
nice when we have such a great nickname
pickle trick because I'm a big fan of
pickle Rick you say pickle trick
so let me tell you a quick storyline we
were talking about this before the show
I was five foot five and a half like I
was about 162 centimeters coming out of
high school in grade 12 I was five foot
five I was a little dude and I was like
and so for me it was like being a little
dude in high school is really hard
because I just hit it late man I just I
had I didn't know I was gonna turn out
tall just like a little guy going into
college I've always identified as like
the short little guy right and that made
it really hard for me so I made like a
decision that I have to work on other
things and I'm really glad I went
through that because it really forced me
to work on my social intelligence like I
read a lot of books like this is before
we had these shows before the internet I
was just buying books on psychology and
like the female brain is a good one
there's one called the male brain it's
really interesting too I was just buying
all these psychology books to learn
about mating habits actually to
understand how to compete in a
Marketplace as a five foot five man
um which was which was more challenging
what's interesting though so all my
decisions that I made in like University
and then afterwards were all about how
to compute as a five foot five man
during that time I grew a lot and then I
became dangerous because now I'm like
tall and I have the social intelligence
I worked on with all the other guys that
were Naturals that have to work on it
for a lot of guys going to the gym is is
sort of that but there's a really
interesting study I read that said that
the top one percent man is is really
easy to Define it's making six figures a
hundred thousand and a six foot tall why
because about ten percent of men roughly
are six foot or taller about ten percent
and about 10 percent of men in the
Western World statistically make a
hundred thousand or more that's a real
stat so ten percent of ten percent is
one percent so if you're if you want to
be in the one percent you got to be six
foot and make six figures for every inch
that you give up for every two and a
half centimeters for our British
listeners for every inch you give up
under six foot tall you compensate for
that with an extra hundred thousand
dollars in income no way so if you're if
you're five eleven it's 200 000 to be
top one percent if you're five ten it's
three hundred thousand and if you're a
five nine it's 400 000. now some of you
guys are listening I'm five eight I have
to make half a million dollars a year
that sounds like a lot it's actually not
it's not that crazy it's very achievable
let me tell you guys something if you
wanna know the statistic of how
achievable it is more men have six packs
sorry reverse that more more men are are
millionaires than those that have six
packs now can you believe your that if
you can go to the gym eventually you can
develop a six-pack you might say yes I
can there are fewer men that have a
six-pack than there are than there are
million men correct because there's not
one out of ten guys have six packs right
right pickle trick you've seen men's
stomach not one out of ten have six
packs
if you're if you like so so you can
imagine that actually becoming a
millionaire is statistically easier uh
than get developing a six-pack again
plugging lgbg guys lgbt.com if you go to
website we recruit men to make a million
dollars there that's why I'm here that's
why I'm here
what what is the quickest way to make a
million dollars other than working
probably pickle tricking right but
um so I don't know the answer to that
but but I'll tell you I know I probably
know about 15 000 millionaires that are
clients of our company so I've I've
talked a lot of them I interviewed a lot
of them starting a podcast literally
interviewing the top one percent of men
to get their life story they all do
different things but there's one thing
they all have in common and that thing
is really really simple they've only
ever done one thing they're not jumping
from job to job every year and a half
two years where they're a rookie again I
don't like it no they accept that in
their work there's something they have
to do which they don't like to do but it
gets the results they need in sales for
us that's picking up the phone and cold
calling nobody likes it but we do it
because we know that it gets a story
nobody likes going to the gym come on
you sell yourself on going to the gym
right guys you have to sell yourself and
convince yourself to do things you don't
like those men don't jump around they
pick a career they stick with it and
they get in the top five percent of
their career and then it's just like
some guys are literally running garbage
disposal companies one of the richest
guys I've ever ever how does a client
sold little stickers for the laundromats
that go on your little hangers when you
dry clean your shirt that was this
business there's all sorts of way to do
it but all of them are stuck to one
thing and they've learned to dominate
the one thing that they do hmm
what what what are the most like do you
know the most common Industries
millionaires are in oh the most common
industry yeah I mean I would say
probably law would be a big one oh
really well yeah law is huge but keep in
mind again when we're thinking about
rich lawyers it's really the top like
five percent that are in that bracket
there's a lot of average guys too uh
banking is there listen everything I'm
in the suit business we have guys I got
I got a guy that's what are we one week
into the month he's made like 20 000 so
far in his first week this month just
selling suits wow just selling suits you
know so sales is a big one
um obviously if you're looking at like
statistically about 50 of all
millionaires are small business owners
about 50 our small business about half
um and though and by the way that half
that that also qualifies in our company
because then our company our sales
people build a clientele they're
building a business kind of like
financial advisors what are insurance
people what are real estate people you
build like your dad built a portfolio of
clients with his I.T company
um but it's but entrepreneurialism and
sales are about half of all the
millionaires in the western world
oh
why do you guys think that men and women
are having such a hard time getting
along today
women because we can't Define which is
which anymore yeah yeah I think that's
one I think yeah I feel like so familiar
really does play a big part in it I do
and there's so many reasons why I don't
know where I'd begin also women trying
to be boss [__] all the time yeah you
can't be a nice feminine Pleasant wife
if you're knackered from work and you're
always trying to go out and get it hard
like a man does you lose
your femininity and then you're gonna
clash with a man
especially and then if he's not
masculine then you're looking down on
him and being a [__] to him really what
can yeah bro does femininity exist in I
really look at things things move
forward right so from
of you were talking about Granddad and
Grandma Etc at those times then we look
at the times in which we live now so the
times we live in which we live now
with social media Etc how like for me I
struggle to see Harold femininity
um would keep its place now so yeah we
can talk about the top one percent Etc
and I can talk about myself and put
myself in a certain bracket I'm not
going to though because it's interesting
to hear comments that are coming from
people when somebody called people Sims
here they have no idea what people do
they have no idea how much money people
make but um
how does femininity see how can you
break that in a society where you're
pumped so much stuff now that women can
be this way and men have to be this way
how do you
take all that though you watch pearly
things fresh and fit and get some and
you take don't listen to all the other
[__] don't listen to cardi b or don't
yeah either you have a private social
media it's sad but I think it's a losing
battle though to be I don't want it I
don't I don't see it getting better I
see like I don't see less girls doing
sex work in 10 years I see more more and
it'll be younger as well younger girls
will start that's disgusting that's
that's I mean yeah I mean and it's hard
I think that's what we wrestle with
because a lot of times like the Trad
cons will come in and say well the world
shouldn't be like that let's just go
back to like our Traditional Values but
I really don't think it'll happen until
we see policy change yeah yeah I agree
with that but honestly how can it get
Beyond WAP do you know what I mean like
what's next I see more girls doing only
fans I see more girls sleeping with more
men
worse but I see women being more
hypergamous yeah I I don't want to live
in that way yeah but I think I think
it's true like I and that's why I think
like there's there's like a a really big
disconnect between like the
conservatives and the red pill because
like the red pill guys are saying well
this is how the world is and we're
adapting where the where the
conservative guys are saying oh no let's
go back in time let's have these
Traditional Values and it's like
it's tough red pill guys are just
conservative guys that haven't uh made a
decision yet to live towards a higher
purpose yeah like there has to be an end
goal you know that's actually one thing
about Tate I don't want to calm on him I
think the guy's a brilliant honestly I
think he's a genius I saw him you know I
was I was like 38 when I first saw him
and my guys were like oh this I'm like
listen I'm like this guy's a freaking
genius and you should listen
um but the one thing and again I don't
want to disparage anything he says
because he's got his own mode of life
and that's totally fine but the one
thing that for me I was like I I had
those same thoughts and I had those same
feelings when I was growing up as well
as what he preaches but I was like but I
needed that higher purpose because I
found it like you can only you can only
um sex yourself into so much
uh happiness until it really just turns
into sadness and I and I wanted that
that higher purpose and that higher
purpose for me was like I want a family
I want a wife and kid I need that
stability that Northstar it's
interesting you say him because team
pushes families he does now he does now
yeah because now especially he's kind of
gonna think a little bit more Islamic in
the prison thing and actually I just
spent a lot of time in Dubai with some
of our Islamic clients one of our
clients is a billionaire we interviewed
him on our podcast that we're coming out
with and he had a really interesting
point about that he took us for dinner
it was like iftar after
um you know and anyways it was he he
really told us the and I grew up Jewish
so I'm like I don't know about Islam and
he really told the philosophy and I was
like that's really appealing I really
like that old world and I really like
that there's a purpose at the end that's
sort of a thing well but I'll give you
an example like I I actually think
you're more red pill than track con I'll
tell you why because because because
I'll give you an example where like the
Trad cons or the conservatives like talk
past the red pill guys when the red pill
guys are saying hey you have to screw 50
girls before you settle down where the
conservatives are saying well just find
the right girl yeah yeah but that's what
I mean that's where I think they like
talk past each other because the
conservatives are like we'll just go to
church find the nice girl but it's like
if you do find a nice girl there's a
line of web guys waiting to date her how
do you compete yeah and and the other
thing is
um like how do you know who's the right
girl if you're not experienced with
women and most of the women are more
experienced they have religion that sort
of sets the rules for them and then the
society around them that upholds that
religion I asked uh one of our
interviewees in India who's uh worth his
company's worth 100 million dollars he's
a he was arranged married and I asked
him about being a ranged mayor and he
explained the philosophy behind that and
I said do arranged married men cheat he
goes never I go why not he goes because
then you lose your business because you
become a social Pride because Society
doesn't support that behavior right but
even in India I went there a couple
years ago feminism's coming and I think
that's like what the the red pill guys
saying it's like okay the idea of like
going to another country and getting a
woman is is good and it's probably a
better outcome but the problem is do I
see in the future feminism spreading and
like it's sad but I think it will we've
seen this before when I was when I was
in India like I remember the lady that
gave us like a tour or whatever she was
a raging feminist and she was telling us
about her friends like divorcing their
husbands and I know it's definitely not
as prep do you know what the divorce
rate in India is today one percent
really is that one lowest the lowest the
divorce rate I found the one one percent
that's you can look it up statistically
I looked I researched before the show I
wanted to know one percent really that's
so interesting I guess you know maybe it
will it will stay the same I just wonder
like I just think it's gonna spread it
probably will but we've seen I mean this
is getting into history like we've seen
the fall of Empires before and it's
always been predicated upon massive
social change based around the loss of
sort of like traditional and right um
you know aurelian virtues right like
that's that's there's a push back
towards that I don't know the big
difference in conservative and red pill
whatever I really think myself as a
libertarian meaning like you should be
able to be free to do what you want I
came to the conclusion that what what I
wanted in my life was a family and
stability and unity in that family I
came to it very naturally it was like
you know what right there's got to be
something higher but and I agree with
you but I think like where a lot of
times the conservative like the sleeping
with 50 girls that's the example I'm
using like the conservatives will say
you can't do that but like the red pill
guys will say well this is the only way
I can the conservative guys are getting
laid way more than the liberal guys and
I think there's like very good research
data to support but not liberal I said
red pillars but like I always hear like
they used to react to Myron's content
and say that they're like oh that's
disgusting advice do you know what I'm
saying sure but I'm saying like that's
where I think they talk past each other
I mean look I I I'm not propagating an
ideology and I'm not propagating a um
like a value system per se because I'm
not a religious or ideological person
but I am but I'm certainly propagating
that men should work to be better I'm
certainly propagating that men should
work on themselves and make themselves
more intelligent and I also realize the
reality I think we see it like it is not
a man's job to keep societies Chast when
they're single it's a man's job to
conquer correct and he needs to learn to
conquer and then he needs to learn how
to conquer the Conqueror within him
contain that danger right
[Music]
they're like I don't know this
conservative or red pills
Russian fit before
was did you find it helpful at first I
was quite wounded yeah yeah I guess so
yeah
because obviously 35
not and I wasn't meant like I was in
early stage of the races since it was
nice relationship when I first started
watching it so at that point I wasn't
even engaged and I was just like wow you
know it just points out the truth it is
true but it isn't Pleasant yeah and I
think it should be taught did it help
you get engaged no I think we we were
all ready yeah yeah no it would have
gone that way anyway but yeah I mean the
same way he
his you know when they talk about a high
value man he's This Tall he's earning
this much and then and my he's not there
but it's inspired him actually to you
know to achieve to yeah I think they do
a lot of good for men and I think a lot
of times they get a bad rap when they
actually do like a time it's really
inspiring for men I'd say like I don't
really know like their podcast offers so
much value when it comes to like the
guests they have on yeah definitely
yeah
what do you think like what's the big
problem in relationships today you said
women why do you think that no I do I
think because
from it's I don't think it's deliberate
though my my I don't think women are
evil or anything but I think we go from
school we go to college we go to Union
we're just following this path you pick
a career and then you're kind of in this
thing that and you don't realize you're
actually going all the way away from
marriage you know you're spending if
you're getting involved in a career
that's going to take you years to to get
uh good at you know and then you're
gonna have to become a harder person
you're spending all this time out of the
house so you're not clean and if you
have kids either you have to leave your
career for a bit to do that but you
can't do it for long so you're you're
leaving dad on the way yeah yeah exactly
and then it just puts pressure but on
the relationship because you're both out
working hard you're both tired you both
come home with problems and yeah you're
just not soft anymore you know what's
interesting I spoke to this woman um
who's like a housewife or like she was a
stay-at-home mom homeschooled her kids
and she was saying it doesn't take as
much money as they propagate to be a
stay-at-home wife uh like she told me
you could get a guy that makes 50 to 60
000 and that's us so here that's like
what like 30 40 50.
but but and she was saying like if you
get like because there's expenses that
you don't realize that pile up when you
bought have jobs so like you both well
here maybe the cars aren't a big thing
but in the US it's like you both have
two cars when she's like and you have to
live in a city where if even if he
commutes longer for work you can get
like a lower
um like a cheaper house in the suburbs
you stay home you can homeschool your
kids if you want to get like a garden
you can grow your own food she was
saying a lot of people like could have
the lifestyle where the woman stays home
they just don't want to like work for it
yeah and when we were younger parents
had less like kids had less you know you
didn't have iPad you didn't have all
these gadgets and you didn't all have
the newest TV and you didn't all have
Skye and Netflix and you know you can
scale it back
yeah and she was even saying with like
clothes she's like they don't need
anything you hand-me-downs for all the
clothes and she was giving me all these
really it's um it's a couple streams ago
guys if you look for it it's actually
really helpful
um because I think a lot of times like
we think we need more than we do for a
lifestyle we can't afford and to us
we're quite spoiled that probably sounds
quite basic and boring and like you're
scrimping and scraping but you'll be
happy yeah you know you the I've been
cleaning up my place more and it's just
relaxing and everything's tidy have you
gone from working and now you stay home
yeah I am at the moment actually we work
together and our boss just happened to
close I I'm a tattooist or I was a
tattooist he was a tattooist uh and the
um yeah the the place shut and then I
was gonna ease off anyway but I thought
well we'll try it and at the moment he's
just trying to you know find other ways
to make money on top of that but we
don't necessarily need it as you say and
it's yeah so it's quite hard it's really
hard as a woman to put all that trust in
a man when you haven't been doing it if
I got quite emotional a couple of days I
just thought oh my God like what if he
doesn't what if he doesn't you know but
if you actually sit down and let him do
it he'll do it and that's the thing I
think they have it in prep and I and I
didn't say evil I was saying an example
of female evil as abortions like I think
that's like women at their worst not not
women as a whole but but what I was like
a lot of times they don't talk about how
like you can go down and lifestyle for a
family yeah you know and like I think a
lot of times women like don't want to go
down in lifestyle to support a family
like how are you gonna afford Botox
every month and kids how are you gonna
afford lip filler fake nails fake hair
like all those expenses I was in Miami
okay and we were talking about like what
you would need to stay home right and
the girls there were saying over two
thousand dollars and I was like girl for
what yeah
for what she's like I need to like and I
was saying I don't know maybe I don't
know a couple hundred yeah yeah and and
but because like what more do you need
food shelter clothes yeah if you have
clothes like what do you need to buy but
I think a lot of times like girls we
want this lifestyle but we don't want
the family and we won't give it up for
the family whereas now obviously I've
always wanted a family never focused
I thought I was focused on it but
obviously I didn't
um and now yeah the girls have got to
think about this younger it matters at
your age if you might not you feel like
you don't want them but you can still
change your mind yeah
I'm curious why don't you want uh to get
married
um
I feel like there's quite a few reasons
really one I don't believe I've seen so
many men get married with women and you
know you do the whole vowel thing and
that don't mean anything
and you've got to pay to get divorced
these days
to me marriage doesn't even seem like
companionship it's more like ownership
to me and I don't like being like
made her feel like I'm owned in a way
you know you said you wanted a man that
with money to take care of you and
everything like that yeah so obviously
that's kind of what Tate talks about
isn't it but like if he's paying your
lifestyle yeah he's supporting you and
he's you know paying for your your name
and everything like that do you not feel
like not owned but like you do know him
something you know what you're right um
I feel like I feel like what I'm trying
to say as well is is that you know when
if I got was something that wasn't
wealthy and I worked really hard for my
staff and he worked hard for his staff
and it comes to the end where you get a
divorce and you've got to split that
I've I've seen so many divorces in my
family that I feel like has just scared
me more not not even because I don't
think marriage is actually really wrong
it probably isn't but in my head I've
just seen too many bad marriages and
it's just put me off so probably that is
worse is I've seen bad marriages and
that's just what's put me off because
there's probably so many happy marriages
out there there is because you said to
yourself that you're happy
um
but yeah I feel like I'm just a bit put
off okay if that's the word and it's
just I've seen women in my family lose
so much from a marriage yeah they've
lost their sanity so
yeah and obviously yes down to them
picking the wrong men but sometimes you
don't even know who you're picking
people seem like the best people ever a
real man shows you and and you know I
mean like most of the time if I ask that
girls like girls say this or what if he
changes my acts change and I always ask
the first question well did your parents
like him no no did you what'd your mom
say oh she hated him oh and so a lot of
times it's just kind of a cop-out to be
honest yeah I think so you can see if a
man like you can see if a guy's
Dependable based on the choices in his
life does he have three kids from three
different women or has he got no one
pregnant outside of marriage does he has
he had a stable job for multiple like
there's ways you can tell yeah but you
see my mom's ex-husband he was amazing
well we thought he was amazing had two
jobs personal trainer he was he was in
the on police which I didn't like really
but yeah he made his choice
um he provided he cleaned he cooked so
amazing it was amazing with kids he
bought me up since I was like eight
years old and never had no suspicion
about him living another life for four
years with another woman bought her a
car and this man actually
like I thought he was like a superhero
that's how good he was you know and then
when you see someone not be that person
you're like how can someone fake a whole
life and then be like that you know and
my mom never had no no
um suspicion of him cheating nothing so
he had like another family or what not
another family but he was with the woman
for four years and he was with my mum
for 12 years he bought her a car he did
loads of things we never knew because he
used to say I'm out working I'm I'm
doing work training how did she find out
um
basically he left the family and my mom
at first he just left yeah he left we
thought he just left yeah but then
um he tried taking the kiss of my mum
tried taking the house off my mum and
then when he was staying in the house
one my mum was away a package came from
the door
um and it was it had his girlfriend's
name on it you know and it had um did
your mom contribute to this at all or
was it just him what'd you mean well
because your mom seems like the common
denominator in these situations so I
just wondered did she contribute to this
at all what to the um let him cheating
sort of thing yeah sometimes women Drive
men to cheat based on how they treat
them I'm not gonna lie my mom's not
perfect at all and I feel like she has
got a lot of issues that she probably
should have fixed you know and I feel
like men do get driven Away by crazy
women sometimes and I feel like a lot of
my mum's older past relationships
probably molded molded her into a person
that was a bit insecure and she did have
a lot of flaws so maybe yeah that was
you know how you can tell
it's really easy right men don't cheat
to leave the relationship they cheat to
stay in the relationship if he cheats
and leaves the relationship then there
are some push them out pretty hard yeah
because that right yeah
okay but it just it could be a better
strategy to try to be like a better
person yeah and then you know like to be
she wasn't a bad person no I didn't say
she was a bad person but I'm saying like
like for you yeah yeah you're still
young yeah it's not you're not done
right yeah but if you make these
decisions for another five to ten years
you will be and you're gonna be in the
same situation
maybe we'll see
um okay
I I think we're gonna close out the show
guys
it's so hot um all right so we're gonna
do final thoughts guys we'll read super
chats after they do um final thoughts so
um tell people where to find you your
social media any anything you want to
say um starting here go around in the
second row oh Mia yeah um my Instagram
is year one Savvy
um I've learned a lot today guys
um I really appreciate being here
um I really liked it I wish I could do
this this was my first podcast so I was
kind of nervous
I don't know I know I didn't say a lot
but hopefully I can do another one again
but yeah it's a wrap
um yeah my name is Vishay Monroe and
tonight
I've actually learned so much things
that there's so much I don't know if
it's because I'm younger or something
but I've learned so much especially from
this gentleman's behind me right here
I've learned so much and it's something
to take on board and hopefully you guys
learned something as well does body
count matter
today's position
does matter but um we got a truth
we got a true Talent I'm gonna go home
reevaluate my whole thinking process
and come back a new man of course
thank you
um find me on Instagram at Taya Bonnie
t-a-y-a Bonnie
um and yeah really good experience met
some lovely people and it's good to
educate yourself because sometimes you
come onto these shows and you think you
know what you know and it only takes a
few people to actually you know tell you
something it makes you realize certain
things like there's a lot of things you
said as well and it actually made me
realize that maybe I'm a bit lying to
myself that yeah I don't want certain
things in life but I do yeah yeah yeah
[Laughter]
okay my name is Katie Owen uh you can
find me on Miss future wifey I'm on
YouTube and Tick Tock insta uh basically
like you just said my my goal obviously
I understand where Pearl fresh and fair
Angie take all the coming where they're
coming from about women but I'm not
willing to accept that it's a lost cause
and I'm here to talk to women younger
women younger women because you know
some of us you know if you passed it a
bit there's not a lot you can do but if
you're young like you there's a lot you
can do yeah yeah
my name is Ryan you can find me on real
underscore or money on Instagram and
today it was a good experience my first
time on a podcast I didn't really say
too much because I was a little bit
nervous but yeah I enjoy it today and
everything
yeah
hey guys I'm Dimitri uh lgfg like look
good feel good lgfg fashion houses our
company I come onto these podcasts uh
because
we're a suit selling company but really
really what we do is we recruit young
men
to learn the science and art of
psychology through sales
of discipline through sales and of
wealth through sales we help young men
learn how to grow and build that's why
I'm here lgfg fashion house if you're
looking for a career
or a career change I implore you to
check us out LG
fashion house and also I just started a
podcast that is going to start I think
the first episode goes live tomorrow
we're uh because we're a fashion company
that sells to very wealthy people I've
been interviewing Millionaires and
billionaires I was in Dubai two weeks
ago then I flew to India with my camera
guy Henry here
then we recorded some in in Estonia in
Eastern Europe and we're doing this
again in London next few days
it's going to be called it is called the
top one percent man podcast and what we
do is it's a very it's not like this red
pilly stuff at all in fact we're just
sitting down with men who are worth tens
and hundreds of millions of dollars and
we're just asking them tell us about
your life experience and and so young
men can learn of what it takes to be
successful all the guys we interviewed
are different some came from broken
homes some came from orphanages
some came from
families that are whole intact today
everybody's different so the top one
percent man podcast if you're gonna
start checking us out and lgfg if you're
looking for a career thank you they love
you in the chat oh I love you guys too I
got it
uh yeah I'm Henry
um all my social media is mostly private
but I do run all the lgfg accounts so
look us up we're on Tick Tock I think
we're on Twitter yes you're on Twitter
yeah we just got our Twitter back
because Peterson uh tweeted one of the
uh suits we made for him a couple times
and finally Twitter let us back into our
account perfect so thank you thank you
Instagram Tick Tock YouTube you can find
us anywhere
lgfg
okay guys
um thank you all for coming this was a
fun show before we close out I'm a
couple announcements before we end the
show I'm the first is we have two clips
channels Pearl daily and just pearly
Clips make sure you go subscribe to both
also guys like the video that's the most
important metric that YouTube uses to
push out these streams I'm gonna Read
Super chats really quick
um also guys sign up for our Google form
all right Google form
um will that's for events we're gonna do
meetups and stuff so it'll be a lot of
fun uh zero Fallout throughout history
women have worked with the average man
they were in fields Farm Gathering and
selling in the market they still had
five plus kids Gore I'm back in the 60s
women were told they didn't need a man
to raise a family how well did that work
out okay I think it's just those two let
me just refresh it real quick to double
check I don't want to do any of you guys
dirty uh okay now we're good
okay guys
um also
um we're going to the US in the next
month so seriously sign up for the
Google form because we are going to do
meetups in um those cities if you want
to see what blessing looks like you know
sign up for the Google form also guys
um we have wife School make sure you go
subscribe to wife school go follow us on
Rumble like the video on your way out
and we'll talk to you next time
[Music]
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame yo what's going on people
King rich is back again with another
podcast good evening and hi and welcome
to Auntie Jenny's video channel to
Jenny's podcast it's your boy The Fresh
Prince of someone
but I've been coffee free for four
months okay I gotta say that how could
everyone have someone out there for them
when there's more women than men now I'm
not saying you have to be submissive to
every old waste man walking around I'm
just saying that it would be femininity
would be in your nature breaking it is
to find somebody you're compatible with
that you'd like not just of your same
generation and that likes the same
things that you do going out having fun
then get out okay okay then then get out
then get out faster then get out I'm not
here to get canceled today most men want
a woman that has some degree of
femininity where they feel like they're
taken care of yeah
I'm submissive and you'll be surprised
because I will say what I want to say
now and I'll say what I want to say with
my mind but my demeanor doesn't change
and I'm gonna look down on him because
at the end of the day whoever you're
with is a reflection of you what has
happened in society that has made the
normal man a waste man I would feel so
so bad asking a guy to buy like a three
thousand dollar bag
foreign
[Music]